[Musique]
francis dupuis déri bonjour bonjour
merci de nous recevoir encore nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet is a
place in curieux que nous sommes en
direct et oui on vous reçoit encore il
ya huit mois on vous a reçus et puis on
avait dit qu'on ferait une nouvelle
interview vous a booké cette interview
la ya quatre mois voilà
quand ça ça va très bien je comprendrais
très si vous avez quelques mots pour
reprendre notre dernière interview sur
votre lecture de la communication
politique sur les gilet jaune sur la
crise en france
commence notre interview oui oui bah
c'était on avait plutôt parler c'est ça
des enjeux de démocratie directe
mouvements sociaux répression policière
on dirait que ça c'est pas tellement
améliorée au niveau de la répression
policière en tout cas et de l'impunité
aussi via sa et du déni des autorités
et puis bon si je peux me permettre je
sors de ces jours ci en fait en france
or un petit livre c'est un cetain et
c'est ce qui s'appelle nous n'irons plus
aux urnes plaidoyer pour l'abstention ou
là j'essaie d'avancer une une réflexion
très très critique comme com vous fait
vous en doutez se re sur l'idée des
élections et de voter comme cul-de-sac
démocratique en fait c'est même pas une
pratique démocratique de toute façon et
je sais de voir si on peut pas plutôt
vive la politique autrement à
l'extériorisation électeurs du parti
politique à l'extérieur de cette es2 de
cages mentale qui nous fait croire que
tout doit passer par par les élections
et la représentation et les élus et les
partis sinon comme on entend souvent il
n'ya pas doré les politiques et donc les
mouvements sociaux sont vain et inutile
ce que je ne sais ce que je ne crois pas
tu prend au dépourvu ce tuto parce que
ce que vient maintenant leur j'aimerais
qu'on avant qu'on finit cette interview
j'aimerais qu'on revienne sur ce fait un
petit tu me prends des pourris parce que
tu vas voir les surprises le livre sort
ces jours-ci
du canada la crise du gilet jaune s'est
vu comment s'est vu de loin donc comme
n'importe quelle crise à l'étranger
c'est la même chose évidemment pour les
médias français on en a parlé beaucoup
au début même si par ailleurs au québec
on est quand même dans une situation
postcoloniale par rapport à la france
donc vous parlez plus du québec parce
que c'est l'ancienne colonie que vous
avez oublié c'est bien dommage parce
qu'après vous avez l'algérie l'indochine
et souhaiterait qu'ils étaient des
colonies plus intéressante pour vous et
mais nous on est restés un peu obsédé
par par la france et donc nos médias par
exemple nos journaux qui ont des fois
pas beaucoup d'argent ils ont souvent
quand même un représentant et
chroniqueur ou un reporter basé à paris
et on reste quand même les yeux tournés
vers vers l'ancienne l'ancienne
métropole est l'ancienne puissance
coloniale et est donc on en entend
parler des élections des mouvements
sociaux on a entendu par dd gilet jaune
mais bon après évidemment quelques
semaines c'est quand même ça reste quand
même une une information qui relève des
affaires internationales du piémont et
en son sens n'est intéressante que dans
les médias officiels évidemment les amis
qui sont intéressés aux mouvements
sociaux ont suivi mais mais il n'y a pas
vraiment eu de relais y3k te rigolo qui
ont essayé de lancer le mouvement des
légendes au québec et au canada mais
seulement des ces tests est minuscule
mais c'était vraiment pas très
intéressant c'était déjà très très
conservateur
csu présence a été présenté comment les
zizou n'a été présentée comme une bande
de casseurs comme des gens qui
arrivaient à finir les fins de mois et
qui commençait à crever de faim s'était
présenté comme des mouvements
instrumentalisé par les ruses des
mouvements astreint instrumentalisé par
le norad c'est décevant parce que c'est
des en fait c'est que là vous avez
l'illusion m'a pas laissé panne ils ont
d'ailleurs mais vous vous avez le nez
dessus c'est ça s'est passé dans les
rues en prêt d'ici tout dans les lycées
mais nous c'était nécessairement des
nouvelles très sommaire c'est comme les
nouvelles internationales dans des
médias qui ont peu de moyens ces
quelques paragraphes quelques
informations de base peu d' analyse peu
de même pas mais pas beaucoup de
théories contradictoires c'est
simplement tant de personnes manifestent
dans t'enlever le ecce terra mais
c'était pas
c'était ça reste un phénomène français
oblige les gens ne sais pas oui
s'intéresser à l'international mais
c'est pas fait pas nous savons qu'on
connaît pas nécessairement bien ski
passe à l'extérieur on en parle
rapidement sans avoir une connaissance
de fois on va on vint rebasculer sur le
thème de notre interview aujourd'hui qui
la crise de la masculinité avec un point
d interrogation exact on va essayer de
dépasser le carcan des mots
c'est quoi la crise de la masculinité
alors le c'était donc le sujet de
2,7 autres lignes que devait présenter
de très très rapidement dans notre vu
qu'on avait fait la dernière fois mais
en fin d'entrevue
qui est inquiétant qui est un projet que
je mène depuis wifi seulement une
quinzaine d'années en fait d'arriver
essaie de comprendre c'est cette idée
que la masculinité serait en crise
qu'est-ce qu'on pourquoi est-ce qu'on
pourquoi est ce qu'on dit sap qui dit ce
qu'est ce que ça qu'est ce que ça a
comme effet de dire ça et donc et aussi
d'en proposer une lecture critique parce
que selon moi c'est un discours
fallacieux c'était une secours faut en
fait et donc et donc pour le résumer en
quelques mots le discours de la crise de
la masculinité c'est l'idée que les
hommes des hommes vont mal les hommes
souffrent c'est que les hommes chez les
hommes c'est nous toi moi et les hommes
mais qu'il souffre en fait à cause des
femmes à cause des femmes et à cause des
féministes et à cause des valeurs
féminines qui domine il dominerait la
société et donc les hommes serait d'une
certaine manière des victimes et et avec
ce discours de crise de masquer une t il
on prétend donc cancon sauf qu'on ait
des victimes et que donc on doit prendre
notre souffrance en considération et
qu'on doit donc considérer que les
femmes surtout les féministes sont un
problème c'est là que c'est la cause de
la crise et donc il faut lire il faut
les critiques il faut les il faut les
endiguer il faut les neutraliser pour
qu'on aime qu'on aille mieux et dans ce
discours il ya nécessairement aussi
l'idée d'une d'une humanité divisé en
deux sexes avec des identités très qu'on
pense qu'ils sont très précises avec des
valeurs ou des comportements des
attributs attributs oui qu'on considère
très très distincts en fait c'est qu'on
parle de sexe opposé là on est vraiment
dans une logique de s'exposer et donc le
masculin serait on connaît mystérieux de
ses passes ray dont nous nous serions
parce que nous sommes des hommes
fort
actif dans la compétition dans la
combativité nous serions autonome
déterminer
qui créent d'ailleurs des grosses
séquelles absolument on va y revenir
très certainement et furent plus
rationnelle et raisonnable aussi que
que les femmes que le féminin le film
l'extrait ceci est un site il y déjà à
l'hystérie oui quand ainsi quand ça va
mal mais quand ça va mieux nous on
allait de douceur ou
hooker ce qu'on appelle le quai en
anglais donc la bienveillance le prendre
soin de l'autre la relation avec l'hôte
et et l'émotion plutôt que la raison la
collectivité plutôt que que la force
individuelle même certains vont dire
même l'égalité l'égalité c'est quelque
chose de féminin alors que l'homme nuit
dans la compétition dans la hiérarchie
dans les structures et dans cette idée
qu'il ya deux sexes différents avec des
valeurs ou des identités ou des des
caractéristiques différentes on va
mettre mènent souvent mettre du côté du
masculin l'efficacité sans la définir
mais on veut drôle de masculin c'est
être efficace est rationnel alors que le
féminin c'est toujours un peu plus floue
flou et donc une fois qu'on a construit
c2c de
ces deux représentations qui sont des
représentations évidemment grande partie
imaginer même si ce processus de sa
procède de notre socialisation a pas
sonné socialiser comme des hommes comme
des femmes dès qu'on est des fois même
avant de naître nous parents nos parents
[Musique]
nous parents projettent quand ils savent
à ça va être un garçon ça va être une
fille joy et des projections qui ce au
niveau du métier au niveau de la couleur
de la chambre au niveau des activités
des gens on prévoit des choses alors que
lundi de même pas nés mais donc ça nous
socialistes mais tout ça c'est de la
construction c est en grande partie ces
de la construction imaginaire mais dans
la crise de la masculinité c'est cette
idée qu'il faut il faudrait en fait
revenir à cette identité masculine et
surtout se méfier de ski féminin et d
attribuer des caractéristiques et des
qualités féminines qui viendraient
intoxiqué comme pas résister
qui serait en fait
des éléments pathologique si on les
retrouve chez les hommes ou dans le
masculin donc s'écroulerait c'est
vraiment une conception de séparatistes
les chroniques de psychiatrisés les gens
pour les co-organiser dans la crise de
la masculinité c'est là qu'on dit que
les femmes sont hystériques elles sont
folles quelle blague d'attention cette
fois parce qu'elles sont complètement
oui ce qu'il faut d'ailleurs au niveau 2
au niveau du blabla toutes les études en
sociologie de la communication et en
psychologie montrent que les hommes on
parle beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
longtemps on interrompt plus souvent les
femmes on est plus affirmatif on les
femmes parlent moins aux moins
interrompre pose plus des questions donc
ça c'est l'idée de la femme babar de
c'est vraiment une
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment un streets
et will donc dans la crise de
masculinité dans le discours de lacker
ou james culte et il ya ces références
qui sont qui relève beaucoup de sueur de
psychologie populaire ou de psychanalyse
populaire ou de référence ou si un peu
floue l'âge des cavernes ou ou à la d1
nous où chacun pas et avec des mâles
alpha donc on de toutes ces idées un peu
qu'on a pris de walt disney ou dans des
albums d'enfants qu'il nous faut croire
qu'on est con est fondamentalement
différent alors que pour revenir à ces
idées là de deux sexes complètement
différent par rapport à des études du
comportement ou des capacités
différentes enfin moi je trouve que
c'est absurde de voir l'humanité comme
ça parce que vraiment si c'était
vraiment le cas on se priverait d'une
moitié de notre humanité ce qui serait
quand même dommage et en fait je pense
dans la réalité même si évidemment il ya
des tendances chez les uns chez les
autres qui peut être plus forte en fait
on a on a en nous toutes ses capacités
et dans la journée on peut des fois être
dans lequel il dit vouer dans la
compétition et défaut dans l'autonomie
et des fois dans la dépendance et des
fois dans la douceur et des fois dans
ses six essais humains s'est passé pas
masculin au féminin quand tu dis dans le
caire c'est dans l'attention c'est ça
donc oui la bienveillance l'attention le
prendre soin de l'autre
les hommes peuvent évidemment prendre
soin des autres d'ailleurs même dans des
organisations pareil forts qui sont
identiques sommes extrêmement viril et
c'était et
et combative pour un exemple ça va
paraître un peu bizarre mais je prends
l'exemple de l'armée par exemple mais
dans l'armée évidemment l'objectif c'est
tuer des ennemis mais en principe il
faut prendre soin d'eux du camarade d'à
côté si on prend pas soin du camarade
d'à côté le la cohésion de l'armée
fonctionne pas donc même dans quelque
chose qui aussi virile et c'était aussi
densifier la masculinité que l'armée il
ya du caire ont fait entre entre soi sur
le champ de bataille il faut pas laisser
le camarade de derrière soi donc
historiquement parlant on a formaté le
discours
donc dans les grottes de lascaux c'est
forcément des mecs qu'on fait les pins
tu vois la
continuer nous n'allons pas débattre
dans la grotte de lascaux c'est
forcément des mecs tu parlais de cro
magnon ou dodo néandertal c'est
forcément les mecs qui allait chasser le
mammouth on précise jamais que 80 % de
l'alimentation est assurée par des
femmes parce que celle qui allait faire
la cueillette c'est elle qui va mettre
quelque chose dans la popote
que on a relégué la femme pour pouvoir
mieux l'accord de risées pour ne pouvoir
mieux comprendre et du mois à prendre
prendre en contrôle la société
tout ça est ce que c'est andy gable à
l'heure actuelle est-ce que c'est pas
devenu dans l'esprit collectif quelque
chose de normal est ce que est ce que
alors c'est très européen parce que en
ex union soviétique
là où dans l'escaut aux sociétés
scandinaves les vikings les femmes
avaient une place très importante elle
serait enterré avec tous les atours du
leader ou de du personnage important en
chine aussi là il y avait des femmes
très très importante en russie pendant
la guerre les femmes se sont foutus au
boulot on prie l'armement donc sur tous
les monuments publics
russie à la femme avec la même taille
que l'homme argos la villa le tantinet
des
filets partisans tout à fait est-ce que
ça la leur on va parler dans une société
plus européen macho technocratique
est-ce que c'est pas trop ancrée dans
l'esprit cognitif
des gens dans la perception des gens
est-ce que dans le monde du travail où
les femmes ont un tiers voire la moitié
de ça les rend moins qu'elle
elles sont elles sont reléguées avec tu
comprends c'est une fin tu apprends
moins cher est ce que c'est encore
jouable de faire basculer une société
plus égalitaire où en fait on va être
condamné avec des mouvements féministes
qui vont se radicaliser ou avec des gens
qui vont se radicaliser
il ya trop de questions je ne sais pas
ce qu est un parfait mais mouvement
funes qui vont se radicaliser venir mais
sur les mouvements filmer les
syndicalistes c'est très simple comme
elles sont pas entendues elles sont pas
respectés ne sont pas écoutés leurs
préconisations ne sont pas operative
homes n'est pas en opération
elle va forcément se radicaliser oui
mais en tout cas le mouvement féministe
qui est souvent
décriée par ses paires ses détracteurs
et ses critiques comme étant justement
trop radical c'est pour ça que je posais
la question pour vous savoir ce que trop
radical nous voit on voit là sur la
chaîne youtube il ya des commentaires
qui sont assassins vous êtes entre mâles
blancs
vous me voulez nom mais dont le langage
c'est radical oui mais le mouvement
féministe c'est probablement un des
mouvements les plus pacifiques et non
meurtrier de meurtriers d'accord oui oui
mais donc est il quand on parle de
radical il faut en terme de harcèlement
une chose comme ça
c'est les femmes qui sont tous un avocat
du diable mais je sais je vous aime bien
mais non mais pour moi le tout ce qui le
discours que qui quitte à présenter le
phénix comme trop radicale extremis
totalitaire il ya même l'expression
féminin il y fut l'expression féminisé
c'est quand même un truc de fou là comme
de comparer l'association comme de
comparer les cultures en asie c'est une
double haie succès c'est une insulte
pour les victimes du nazisme qui sont
des millions de personnes exterminées et
c'est une insulte pour le film de
personnes etc les femmes qui sont qui se
font tuer qui se font tuer et harcelés
et il ya un moment du du masque une asie
sous du masculinisme nazisme il y en a
deux à l'extrême droite mais mais tout
ça c'est des stratégies de 10 de
discrédit du mouvement féministe qui je
le répète là si on le compare à d'autres
si on compare la situation des femmes à
la situation
d'autres à d'autres situations
politiques qu'on connaît au xxème siècle
19e siècle 21e siècle exemple des gens
des populations par exemple qui était
très pas ou très peu représentée dans
les parlements ou dans les gouvernements
dans les états qui étaient discriminés
au niveau de l'emploi qui avait moins
d'accès à la propriété qui avaient des
individus de leur communauté qui se
faisait il y en avait un ou deux ou
trois par semaine qui se faisait
assassiner par des membres du groupe
dominant mais on sait ce que ça est ce
qu on sait ce que ça a donné ça donnait
des mouvements armés ça donnait des
révolutions des guerres civiles ces 6 1
6 1 dans des situations comme ça et donc
le mouvement féministe
si on le compare à ça il est absolument
pas radical on prend on pourrait même
dire qu'il n'est peut-être pas assez
radicale quant aux états unis ou dans
d'autres endroits il ya
un noir par exemple une personne noire
une personne haram qui se fait
assassiner par la police on appelait ça
des bavures policières il peut avoir des
émeutes c'est une des causes premières
des émeutes urbaines depuis dix quinze
vingt en occident c'est ce qu'on appelle
les fameuses bavure policière se doit
car la police tue
quelqu'un généralement c'est un homme
brisé et qui salue en pleine immunité
après ça y ait pas de procès ou si un
procès de policiers grâce et c'est
sérieux type et qu'elle il ya des
émeutes des femmes là on le sait
maintenant en france l'a aujourd'hui on
peut pas l'ignorer la ses environs qui
meurent tous un jour et vous tous les
deux trois jours donc sans appel ces
féministes et des moeurs parce que ce
sont des femmes et non pas le type qui
tue sa conjointe parce qu'elle le quitte
il l'aurait pas tué son colloque c'est
son colloque lui annonce qui s'envole
assez pas c'est donc c'est la femme est
assassinée quand est ce qu'il ya des
émeutes féministes ou des émeutes de
femmes qui n'a pas et donc le mouvement
féministe il est il vraiment très très
très très très très très modérée il
ouvert il est tolérant mais il est plein
débat moi je parle pas au nom du
mouvement fait mais ce méga plein il ya
plein de débats dans le mouvement fait
mais c'est déjà aidé il ya des femmes
qui sont plus ou moins
arrêtés sur leurs précédents d'autres
qui sont plus ouverts mais ça c'est
comme tout c'est comme tout mouvement ya
playoffs il ya plein de tendance et
jamais je n'ai jamais eu de réunion
ouverte qu aux femmes mais bel et bien
sûr que oui rejetons les hommes ben oui
j'espère qu'il y en a eu ses préceptes
de noces et le précède de ses préceptes
de non-mixité les mouvements sociaux les
groupes les groupes discriminés ils ont
ils sont toujours dans ils ont toujours
des moments ils sont dans des réunions
seulement fermi cc c'est le cas des cinq
gains et cède quand on n'évite pas le
patron de discuter avec avec 12 h
éventuellement éventuellement on va les
voir le patron pour négocier mais dans
la réunion syndicale il ya pas le patron
c'est non c'est l'absurde et il n'y a
pas il n'ya pas les gardiens de sécurité
du patron il n'ya pas les cadres les
cadres intermédiaires dans une réunion
ii dans une réunion même dans les
réunions de groupes politiques donc par
exemple tu es dans un groupe anarchiste
ou thé dans un groupe trotsky et soudés
dans un groupe écologiste dans le groupe
et que le juste invite pas les
pétroliers à lillers pour du fait d'un
polype autres lire pour discuter avec
toi et chez les anarchistes david polly
trop stressée je suis trop triste avec
pas les anarchistes donc tout ça c'est
des réunions non mix mais quand c'est
des seuls moments où ça énerve séquences
et des personnes restées ou cd perso
c'est des femmes
dix bagues en or et un moment on aurait
besoin de se réunir un peu entre nous
pour partager sur nos expériences
réfléchir discuter développer des
stratégies puis peut-être éventuellement
reviennent définissent ces parades sont
lesbiennes y alliez ce après que les gsm
a d'ailleurs pourrait avoir des raisons
de l'être séparatisme haïk mais ça
existe à peu près pas toutes ces femmes
qui sont en en mixte et elles sont en au
mixte et de trois heures une fois par
mois ou par deux mois et puis j'apprécie
à emmerder non plus peut-être ne pas se
faire emmerder mais évidemment que c'est
pas pour se redresser pour pouvoir
réfléchir elle même par rapport à des à
des questions importantes pourraient non
mixtes et c'est un principe politique de
base pour n'importe quel gros politiques
ou sociales qui se mobilisent est ce qu
on peut faire des réunions non mixtes
avec que des blancs que des noirs tu dis
ce que tu veux avec fb oui mais avec des
noirs bien sûr qui est dans le mouvement
des droits civiques dans le mouvement du
black paru aux états unis il y avait des
réunions où ils ont même en fait exclu
les blancs parce qu'il réalisait que
quand il y avait des blancs dans leur
réunion cette sacrée plein d'effets
pervers dans la réunion des fêtes
inégalités défaits 2 et ils étaient dans
des processus d'émancipation où il
devait en fait développé une conscience
individuelle et collective où il se
disait mais en fait je me sens la
capacité de me tenir debout et de
mobiliser contre contre les blancs il ya
des moments où ils devaient se retrouver
juste entre afro américains
afro-américaine et puis après ça ils se
retrouvaient dans des coalitions dans
les coalitions dans des coalitions plus
large et c'est quelque chose de jeu
c'est quelque chose qui arrive qui
arrive tout le temps dans les mouvements
d'émancipation dans les mouvements de
dans les mouvements de révolte dans les
mouvements sociaux d'un nouveau peut
plaire ce moment et je reviens avec
l'exemple des syndicats est l'exemple
des syndicats c'est c'est sur une base
de classe et sont une base d'emploi de
salaires et et on va pas dire ah non
mais le le syndicat et qui est méchant
et parce qu'il exclut patron il exclut
les actionnaires ben oui mais cécile
syndicats il a besoin de moments pour
réfléchir ensemble comment à leurs
conditions concrètes à pouvoir discuter
sans que le patron voit
quels sont les enjeux des discussions
pour pouvoir apprécier le plus fort face
aux patrons
un internaute qui nous dit les femmes
chasser aussi de mammouth oui ça c'est
un très bon point merci internautes
en fait je vais être même plus
on est désolé des travaux chez le voisin
oui oui on à coups de marteau il y à il
y à cette idée que
qu on sait qu est-ce que qu'est-ce qui
était la préhistoire or
claudine cohen et d'autres exclus le
livre la première femme j'espère que je
me trompe pas là au niveau du prénom et
d'autre en fait on écrit sur cette
fameuse prise toit par rapport à ce
qu'on sait des rôles des hommes et des
femmes est en fait on essaie revient ce
que tu disais tout à l'heure sur
d'autres exemples en russie ou ailleurs
où les femmes avaient des rôles beaucoup
et stéréotypé ou limitée dans la société
et donc ces spécialistes de la
préhistoire m'ont fait comprendre en
fait que les meilleurs la meilleure
position la position la plus honnête
intellectuellement au sujet de la
préhistoire c'est une sorte d'agnos
tisme c'est à dire on ne sait pas et on
ne saura jamais réellement comment
fonctionnaient les communautés humaines
il ya 20 30 milan ou de l époque de ce
qu'on appelle la prison où on est prêt à
l'époque de ce qu'on appelle l'âge des
cavernes on ne sait pas pourquoi on ne
sait pas parce qu'en fait ce qu'on a
c'est un bout d'os ici un autre bout de
son nez depuis un bout de crâne en
sibérie et là des fois en plus on sait
même pas c'est un homme une femme sont
un adolescent une adulte gerra on est
dix fois des cibles des sépultures avec
un bout de lensois bout'chou plus de blé
ou des choses comme ça et et à partir de
là on prétend qu'on est capable de
savoir qui chassait qui faisait la
vaisselle qui passait l'aspirateur dans
la caverne qui peignait qui dansait des
danses à la lune serait complètement
idiot que l'on a on ne sera jamais
réellement commencé société fonctionnait
et la seule manière dont on peut
prétendre le savoir c'est en projetant
des expériences contemporaines ou
récentes sur la prise toi y en a un ça
fonctionnait comme ça mais cette c'est
une illusion on ne sait pas ce qu'on
peut très bien imaginer considérant
l'anthropologie l'histoire
l'ethnographie les ex de ce qu'on voit
en fait c'est que
à cette époque comme comme à d'autres
époques plutôt que d'avoir une
conception très figée de qu'est ce qu'un
homme qu'est ce qu'une femme qui chasse
le même hôte qui qui s'occupe des
enfants à la caverne plutôt qu'à voir
cette idée très figé qui ressemble en
fait drôlement une banlieue nord
américaine avec un bon galop
où j'ai grandi le père qui par le matin
en au boulot et là la mère qui s'occupe
des enfants c'est très stéréotypé en
fait il est très probable que et dans la
préhistoire et il est plus que probable
c'est confirmé que dans les communautés
humaines qui ont peuplé la terre pendant
des milliers d'années il y avait en fait
plein de manières d'organiser la vie
familiale les vies amoureuses les
bisexuels le rapport des enfants avec
les adultes leurs efforts le rapport des
adultes avec les aînés
avec avec la mort avec le travail avec
la chasse avec la nourriture et cetera
alors avec l'art les identités sexuelles
n'y avait pas juste homme/femme féminin
masculin on pouvait changer d'identité
certains moments dans la vie où il y
avait des des troisièmes identité du
gtrra il faut il faut il faut il faut
s'informer un peu leur vie en fait quand
on s'informe on réalise que le
l'expérience humaine et si possible de
faire en tant qu'être humain en tant que
que dans nos rapports avec les autres
dans nos rapports amoureux sexualité 3
c'est beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus
diversifiée et intéressant pour le moins
que cette idée super figée de il ya un
modèle qui viendrait de l'âge des
cavernes rechausser le mammouth qui est
extrêmement réducteur simplice manque
d'imagination complète est ce qu est ce
que dans tout vous tiens tu parles du
fait qu la pub le fait d'utiliser des
nichons je suis pas comme ça avait des
missions et des fesses pour vendre du
shampoing
vous vendre des bagnoles ou pour vendre
tout un plan chose qui représenterait la
virilité la masculinité la vitesse c est
ce qu il faut commencer par neutraliser
ça une bonne fois pour toutes est-ce
qu'il faut passer des lois est ce qu'il
faut est-ce qu'il ya déjà des lois
je sais pas s'il faut commencer en tout
cas moi je moi je moi j'ai pas d'accès
acquis qui produit les publicités donc
peut-être les personnes qui ont une voix
bien tu prends là maintenant non mais ça
c'est le jeu confirmé d'ailleurs ça fait
écho à ceux un des axes du discours de
la crise de la masculinité qu'on entend
québec en tout cas je sais pas sur
l'antenne c'est c'est
la preuve que
il ya une crise de masse culte et c'est
que les hommes sont toujours représentés
comme des losers dans les publicités ou
des choses comme ça alors qu'en fait on
doit pas regarder la même télévision
parce que moi jouer exactement ce que tu
mentionnes c'est à dire l'homme qui
conduit la voiture de luxe avec une
belle montée
une femme séduisante mais ce jeu plus
jeune que lui à côté de fleurs ou
l'homme qui va à la banque pour pour
avoir un pré où est on encore ces images
un petit fait l'imbécile derrière on a
encore sa des publicités avec avec tout
à fait tout à fait et des fois je fais
des blagues avec ma copine c'était
encore un brainstorm qui a pas été très
longue parce qu'ils sont roms avec telle
approche à la première idée donc ça
c'est sûr qu'au niveau de la pub on
n'est pas dans on est très très peu dans
la déconstruction de
vider les stéréotypes et d'émettre des
genres et sauf certaines agences
publicitaires qui veulent justement
attirer l'attention et qu'ils essayent
de faire un petit coup de subversion
mais a défendu cette raison la pub par
définition c'est toujours à des faits à
des fins de profit des mains donc c'est
pas là que c'est pas de la guadeloupe va
venir le l'égalité la liberté est ce que
tu t'es intéressé à la religion est ce
que la masculinité est mis en avant dans
le temps les religions que ce soit chez
nous oui ce soit en arabie saoudite que
ce soit en indonésie que ce soit en
amérique du sud ou en afrique oui alors
avant de répondre spécial un petit petit
préambule tu fais quelque chose manque
donc
dans mon livre où je déconstruis ce
mythe de la caisse damas culte et moi je
ne savais pas en commencé à travailler
mais j'ai découvert en retraite a
commencé à faire ça d'ailleurs parce que
ça m'énervait parce que j'étais en fait
j'écris souvent sur le coup de
l'énervement ça m'évite eu une
psychanalyse probablement et donc par
exemple je vais faire un petit livre sur
les black blocks parce qu en fait j'en
avais marre de tout le monde qu'ils
aient à cdc des jeunes voyous casseurs
qui n'ont aucune idée politique et qui
viennent je sais tout ce qui lie
mouvement que je sais c'est pas sérieux
ça s'est passé parce que les black
blocks les gens arrivent les beaux
qu'ils ont des idées politiques qu'ils
ont une réflexion on peut être en
désaccord et on lui doit ça marche pas
on peut dire tout ce qu'on veut mais on
peut pas dire que c'est d une sorte
d'aton fou de rage pure qui naquit
n'avait rien apparaître la politique
donc ça ça m'énervait donc j'écris
j'écris j'écris compte la brute était
plus serré la répression politique
policière ce qui est un peu futiles
parce qu'évidemment écrire des livres
s'empêchera jamais la police de
continuer à faire ce qu'elle fait en
cours mais
parce que sinon ça se retrouve ça serait
trop facile le choc mais mais ça
m'effraie d'accord mais ça aide à passer
ma frustration d'écrire des livres pour
dénoncer la beauté des policiers et jean
faire qu un an ah mais ça c'est un autre
sujet en est on en aurait une objection
sur la police nettement je sais pas mais
on essaie des choses mart a écrit un
livre ce qui est sûr c'est que c'est pas
ça qu'il suffit mais
[Musique]
met donc en faisant de l'âge de mon
bureau un peu en tout cas j'ai retrouvé
des découpures de journaux je gardais en
fait des creux n'est que qui prétendait
qu'il y avait la crise de la masculinité
au québec au début des années 90 et donc
ça fait longtemps que ça m'énerve et moi
je disais c'est absurde que les hommes
se disant crise de la masculinité alors
que si je regarde autour de moi je vois
bien qu'en fait les hommes en général on
est vraiment peu souffrir je ne dis pas
que les hommes on est tout le temps
heureux et que tout va n'est pour nous
et tout ça mais qu'en général les hommes
en tant qu'hommes ils sont plutôt
privilégié par rapport aux femmes on est
encore majoritaire dans les grandes
institutions les actions quiconque les
actions importantes le parlement les
partis les grands syndicats l'armée la
police la haute finance les plus grandes
fortunes de france les actions
internationales
les grandes religions le sport quel est
le sport le plus prestigieux dans lequel
il ya plus d'argent même des choses qui
sont pas du sport comme la formule 1 il
s'est dit dizaines de millions de
dollars qui sont investis par les c'est
juste pour les hommes de former loyer
juste des hommes qui qui qui tourne en
rond dans l'ordre dans leur voiture il
ya des femmes lemay sont en bikini à
côté pour faire vendre les ferrari mais
c'est 10 millions $ pensez-y parapluie
au ciné pour porter et est donc le sport
le plus prestigieux c'est le sport
masculin
celui qui a le plus d'argent celui qui
le plus vu celui qui a le plus de
ressources
ce qu'on appelle le crime organisé ma
compréhension la mafia cdcc contrôlée
par des hommes ça à moins que il ya
quelque chose que je n'ai pas compris ce
qu'on appelle les réseaux taurus et des
hommes donc en fait je me dis comment
penser que l'homme est en crise
d'identité que la masculinité est
incluse dans un monde pareil c'est
absurde et donc j'étais très énervé
c'est pour ça que j'ai commencé très
vite là dessus et donc
en commençant trop bien là dessus j'ai
rêvé qui évidemment y avait d'autres
personnes qui avaient travaillé
là-dessus
femmes ab bien sûr vous fait lire le
livre pour les années 80 par exemple aux
états unis les années reagan ya un livre
très important qui les lie de suan phlu
10 qui s'appelait backlash qui étaient
traduits en français par backlash
c'est que c'est comme ça l'édition
française
et
c'est souvent comme ça en tout cas et
donc
ça c'est un lit vraiment qui a été très
important début des années 90 pour me
faire prendre conscience de de ce type
de discours
au québec il y a eu
en le 6 décembre 1989 donc ça va bientôt
faire trente ans un événement terrible
c'est un jeune homme est entré à l'école
polytechnique donc l'école polytechnique
de l'universel montréal le sait et 189
donc on est à la fin de la session c'est
le dernier cours avant les examens ils
rentrent dans une salle de classe et il
demande aux hommes de se mettre à gauche
il demande aux femmes de se mettre à
droite et demande aux hommes de sortir
et ils tirent sur les femmes et il va y
avoir la plupart sont abattus sur place
quelques survivante dans le dans le tas
de corps me désole de de cette image et
puis l'homme va continuer à marcher dans
l'école polytechnique qui va tuer au
final très étudiante et une adjointe
administrative dont 14 femmes jeu des
femmes et finalement ils se suicident e
sur place et il est il laisse une lettre
sur il a une lettre sur lui et dans la
première classe on saura plus tard parce
qu'il ya des survivantes qu'il avait dit
déclaré aux femmes ou première étudiante
il y avait dit vous savez pourquoi vous
êtes si c'est parce que vous êtes des
féministes ejei les féministes et vous
allez payer pour ça il l'attiré et
source dans sa lettre il disait aussi
les financements toujours gâcher la vie
j'ai eu les féministes québécois donc
j'ai les féministes jeu et les
féministes et et
je leur déclare la guerre c'est une
déclaration de guerre et il avait une
liste de 2 deux femmes qu'il avait
identifié c'était avant internet mais 88
la première femme à la chambre de
commerce de montréal la première femme
policière la première femme pompière la
première femme
commentatrice sportive à la radio dont
vous voyez un peu la mentalité donc lui
voulait vraiment comme conserver des
secteurs d'emploi bien masculin et donc
des caves et une femme c'est une femme
de trousser une femme qui envahissait un
secteur selon lui il dit je réunis les
depuis mais en fait j'ai pas le temps
donc ils attaquent ils attaquent ils
attaquent polytechnique ça c'est en 89
mois l'époque j'étais étudiant lignes de
recettes montréal j'étais pas sur le
campus au mot à ce moment là mais c'est
sûr que c'est un moment qui a été
totalement bouleversant
et qui a ouvert en fait curieusement
plutôt qu'en fait avoir une sorte de
moment de choc la société québécoise est
de réfléchir à la situation des femmes
et à la violence contre les femmes ce
qu'il fait mener sont demandés
presqu'immédiatement plutôt que de
constater aussi qu'à l'école
polytechnique à l'époque il n'y avait
que 19 % de femmes donc en fait les
femmes étaient très minoritaires
polytechnique
sa ouvert en fait un espace pour des
discours extrêmement virulent contre les
féministes et un discours de
victimisation des hommes en 10 ans il
faut le comprendre si s'il a fait ça
c'est parce qu'en fait c'est très
difficile de te nomme aujourd'hui
c'est le résultat en fait damner de fait
mine est ce qui a mené à cet assassinat
de masse j'ai juste pour terminer et
très rapidement si vous voulez en savoir
plus sur cette histoire là qui sait les
trente ans dans quelques jours
je vous conseille de lire un livre 2000
sable est donc une sociologue
montréalaise mais il semblait bel abbès
elle a écrit un livre qui s'appelle
jouis les féministes qui la phrase du
tueur
le souci c'est le 6 décembre 89 et 6 8 6
aux éditions du remue ménage c'est
disponible en france maintenant et il
explique bien en fait vingt ans de
débats sur 7 cet attentat anti féministe
était réellement il n'attend pas une
forte fumée c'est donc moi j'ai été
nourri percée par ces événements par ces
situations par ses observations et donc
tout ce discours de la crise de mauvaise
qualité mais m'énerver dans le bouquin
est ce qu'il explique le parcours du
ghana ce qu ils tancent politique elle l
explique l explique l explique
l'événement à expliquer ce qui s'est
passé concrètement et après ça elle
explique comment en fait la société
québécoise s'est divisée déchiré à
travers les médias pendant 20 ans sur
sur l'interprétation le sens à donner à
cette donc elles expliquent bien en fait
il ya tout un pan de deux personnalités
publiques qui ont essayé de d'excusés ou
de justifier c'est peut-être un peu fort
mais en tout cas si ici d'excusés de
féminicide ben justement en dix ans en
dix ans ben là il faut qu'on ait en fait
ils ont fait porter la responsabilité de
ce massacre antiféministe ils ont fait
porter la responsabilité au féminin ce
temps dans les films ils sont allés trop
loin le film et son tour de cannes du
film reste au québec en estrie les
hommes --dont qui est bien normal qu'un
jour comme ça il y ait quelqu'un qui qui
était peu un type explose parce que ne
passe que les hommes ne peuvent plus au
québec c'est ce qu'il disait on est en
89 et il laissait penser que qui avait
une injustice à polytechnique parce
qu'en fait par exemple on disait ah oui
mais on encourage les femmes à rentrer à
polytechnique alors que les hommes que
les hommes son pote encourage à
polytechnique alors que je répète il y
avait 19 % de femmes à polytechnique
seulement elle était elle était
clairement minoritaire et que cet homme
était obsédé par une femme ici une femme
blâmer mais les mails et les des
personnalités publiques antiféministe
évidemment machistes ou si on utilise
cette cette situation pour en fait faire
la critique féministe et des fumées se
sont même sentis avait de l'envié se
sont sentis coupables après ça se sont
sentis sur la défensive je vais passer
une question d'internet qui est
relativement révélateur du la discussion
qu'on est en train d'avoir
si une cure view vous allez faire que
dans le politiquement correct trois
points d'interrogation c'est ennuyeux à
mourir demandez lui d'expliquer pourquoi
l'homme privilégié représentent 75 % des
suicides et plus de 90 % des accidents
mortels au travail si on a des branleurs
payer plus pour rien faire point
d'interrogation
qu'est ce que ça te fait penser cette
question c'est quelqu'un j'ai pas trop
compris la fête sur les bras leur payait
cher on peut ce bras les 90%
si on est des branleurs pays plus pour
rien faire d'accord il faudra qu'ils
nous expliquent le suicide c'est merci
pour merci pour cette intervention très
pertinente et et donc il va cette
personne va être content de savoir que
dans mon livre justement il va trouver
plusieurs pages de d'analystes de
discours sur le taux de suicides
masculins
est en fait dans le livre il y a tout un
chapitre ou en fait je déconstruis 4,5
axe 2
discours de la crise de masse culte et
donc le fait que le taux de suicides
masculins soit plus élevé que le taux de
7 des femmes les difficultés scolaire
des garçons les divorces
dans des situations il ya des enfants et
les violences et où si la prétendue
difficultés de draguer ou de séduire
donc pour la question prise précisément
du suicide et là je
je dis tout de suite que c'est un sujet
très délicat je sais pas si vous avez
des gens qui se sont succédé dans votre
entourage - journée 2-3 malheureusement
dans les 10 15 dernières années cette
situation très très très douloureuse et
qu'on est compliquée qui qui sont
bouleversantes et qui nous hante pendant
tout le temps fait donc la question du
site c'est quelque chose de compliqué et
mais quand on regarde dont les taux de
suicide au québec ça a été un argument
longtemps utilisé pour prétendre qu'une
crise de la masculinité c'était le taux
de suicides masculins était de 3,4 fois
plus élevé que le taux de ceux de
féminin
et donc on se dit là il ya quand même
quelque chose de révélateur sap a l'air
facile d'être un homme la preuve les
hommes se succèdent beaucoup plus que
les femmes donc c'est la preuve que
c'est d'être un homme et puis en plus y
avait même des ddd groupe de pères
séparés ou divorcés ou des personnalités
masculines et ce qui est un peu c'est
les femmes qui possèdent un massa se
suicider dans les situations de divorce
par exemple et donc non seulement non
seulement les hommes se suiciderait plus
que les femmes mais en plus ce serait de
la faute des femmes c'est ça suscite
donc double discours de victimisation
des hommes fassent face aux femmes le
problème avec ce discourt et c'est un
problème sérieux là je remets pas du
tout je minimise pas du tout le problème
du suicide c'est vrai c'est très très
douloureux
catastrophé que pour l'entourage
le problème c'est que si on veut poser
ce problème sérieusement et c'est
trouver des pistes de solution il faut
il faut prendre ça au sérieux et pas par
amener des solutions qui vont en fait
aggraver le problème je pense que je
pense ça peut être une bonne idée et est
clair c'est que l'instruction gré à gré
est clairement l'idée de revaloriser par
exemple une mascotte une masculinité
viriliste
stéréotypes ecce terra chez les épis
dialogue les sociologues et les
spécialistes des des situations de près
similaires ont tendance à dire non en
fait la masculinité stéréotypes et
clichés viriliste est en fait un facteur
de risque en situation de crise
suicidaire pour au moins deux raisons ou
3 en fait c'est que dans la
socialisation masculine d'être viril
fort dominant en contrôle de la
situation
ça pourrait faire en fait qu'on est
paradoxalement
des fois je voudrais plus affectées par
des par les échecs importants que des
femmes j'ai pas que pour les femmes
c'est pas important de ces événements
douloureux de vivre des échecs mais on
est des identifications beaucoup plus
homogène par exemple un autre emploi
ou à la conjugalité est donc là on va
vivre ça comme un échec et on a
l'impression que c'est une destruction
de notre de notre identité mais c'est
lié à la socialisation masculine et
c'est un facteur de risque et l'autre
facteur de l'est très important qui est
liée à l'identité masculine est
évidemment par rapport au suicide c'est
le rapport à la violence c'est qu'on
pense qu'être un homme vrais hommes
c'est être capable de violence et c'est
d'aimer les armes à feu par exemple et
les épidémies rock 10 en situation de
crise suicidaire quand vous avez un
fusil à la maison et 80 ou 85% des armes
à feu sont en fait propriété masculine
c'est des hommes qui sont propriétaires
des armes à feu mais en fait c'est vrai
c'est un facteur de risque et vous avez
malheureusement plus de chance de
compléter un suicide si vous essayez de
vous suicider avec une arme à feu qui
avait par exemple des médicaments est
donc cette idée de du suicide qui serait
le résultat d'une crise de la
masculinité est donc ce serait la preuve
qu'une crise hamas culte est en fait
c'est peut-être l'inversé en fait si un
taux de suicide de si important du côté
des hommes par action comparé aux femmes
c'est peut-être en fait aller vers ce
que la masculinité viriliste stéréotypes
et clichés
dominatrice forte et elle est encore
très présente très forte très prégnante
et c'est un facteur de risque mais sur
le site je veux je complétais en disant
de trois autre chose importante c'est
qu'en fait de prétendre que le suicide
et le résultat par exemple d'une
féminisation de la société ou de l'
influence des féministes ou de
déclassement des hommes face aux femmes
et un discours fallacieux parce qu'en
fait si on revient ou la fin du 19e
siècle on peut dire que la fin du
deuxième c'est que les femmes et les
féministes contrôler la france par
exemple on a des jeux de tout souci d'
équivalent et dans des pays où à ma
connaissance les fumées seront pas pris
encore le contrôle je pense à la russie
ou au mexique ma connaissance en russie
c'est pas les pouces et riot qui
contrôle le kremlin s'est peut-être
plutôt poutine qui a pas l'air d'être en
crise de masculinité du tout l'air ou au
mexique en fait on a des écarts en
termes de taux de suicide beaucoup plus
important dans les pays comme ça que en
france au québec donc c'est quand même
savez ça veut dire quelque chose par
rapport à cet argument et
et
finalement il y aurait beaucoup d'autres
choses à dire que j'essaie d'expliquer
dans le livre pour les personnes que ça
intéresse peuvent aller voir ça en
bibliothèque ou ailleurs mais sur la
question du sud qui est un problème
complexe mais
prendre le suicide ou si comme le le la
preuve ultime d'un malaise existentiel
de la condition masculine c'est
évidemment peut-être la forme la plus
spectaculaire de malaise existentiel
mais il ya d'autres formes de malaise
existentiel qui sont féminins il y à
l'anorexie par exemple est un mâle
presque exclusivement féminin la
dépression et il faut pas oublier les
tentatives de suicide sont à peu près
égales entre les deux sexes mais là
encore comme les hommes utilisent des
moyens plus drastiques parce que ses
associés à la masculinité il complète
plus souvent tus et n'en fait en termes
de tentatives de suicide ont à peu près
l'équivalent donc le suicide est un
problème réel grave il ya réellement un
taux de suicides masculins supérieur au
taux de succès de féminin mais ça ne
démontre pas en fait que les hommes
souffrent à cause des femmes ou qu'il
souffre d'une crise de l'identité
masculine à la limite même ça prouve
inverse que l'identité masculine va très
bien si si je te dis quand les femmes
choisiront les meilleurs d'entre nous le
mood ira mieux ça me fait penser à quoi
les femmes choisir les meilleurs d'entre
nous voilà revenus c'est en été c'est
moi je suis hétérosexuel donc j'espère
que je suis un des meilleurs d'entre
nous parce que retrouvez tout seul mais
alors c'est pour compléter le stéréotype
ce qu'on appelle du moins ce que la
société du xxième siècle occidentale
appelle les plus belles femmes c'est à
dire un peu rachitique avec des glandes
mammaires surdimensionnées ou dopé au
silicone avec la grande toisons blondes
et très sportive
est-ce que ce stéréotype là le fait
qu'elle soit toujours avec des gens
on sait encore l'inter au type les mains
très riche et très vieux oui donc ça ça
le ca donne l'objectif au jeune homme de
se trouver le même type de femmes et
ainsi de suite comment on fait pour
déconstruire ça on doit dire aux femmes
arrêtées de sortait avec des vieux
libidineux plein de pognon on doit dire
quoi on doit dire aux vieux libidineux
de se faire soigner un dos douloureux ou
c'est normal
en fait ces situations elles sont
évidemment est tous là mentionné dans ce
que tu disais que tu as été évoquée par
exemple l'argent elles sont évidemment
le résultat est même là d'une certaine
manière la démonstration de l' avantage
tendancielle des hommes face aux femmes
dans la société face à l'argent est
là il ya un double jeu et et moi c'est
mon cas c'est le cas de c'est vraiment
un phénomène tendancielle c'est que les
hommes hétérosexuels nous avons tendance
en fait à nous mettre en couple avec des
femmes plus jeunes et donc là il ya un
double avantage c'est à dire que
tendanciellement les hommes vont avoir
plus d'argent évidemment il ya des
contre-exemples mais tendanciellement
c'est une tendance générale les hommes
ont plus d'argent que les femmes mais en
plus si on est en couple avec des femmes
qui sont plus jeunes mais en fait on a
une longueur d'avancé dans la carrière
professionnelle par exemple des cumulus
dans l'accumulation de richesses ou dans
l'accumulation de deux propriétés
parce que si 4 5 6 et 7 ans de
différence dans le couple ben
nécessairement l'homme en enseignement
va être plus avancées en termes de
capitalisation des cumulation de
richesse ou de d'avancement
professionnel chez terrain donc ça vient
ça vient ça vient doubler cet avantage
monétaire est dans une société libérale
comme la nôtre dans ce qu'on appelle le
libre marché qui ne ment pas libre du
tout d'avoir plus d'argent c'est par
définition un avantage et là on se
retrouve avec des situations qui peuvent
avoir l'air étrange de très jeunes
femmes par exemple qui se trouve ce
qu'on appelle en anglais un chocolat dis
donc le papy le papy multimillionnaire
mais ça c'est celle ci c'est la
conséquence de rapports entre les sexes
qui sont très inégalitaire et dans
certains moments incertains dans
certains lieux extrêmement inégalitaire
et cette inégalité extrême a des effets
il ya des femmes qui font des mots je je
je je je suis pas eu de discussion
nécessairement avec ces femmes là mais
elles font des choix où elles se disent
là j'ai une option comme elle a qu'un
pas divorcer c'est ça
oui oui non non c'est pas du tout ça que
je veux dire c'est à dire que comment je
dirais quand vous avez des différences
des différences tellement grandes en
termes de revenus ça pervertit les
rapports entre les gens d'avoir d'avoir
des telles différences à peu peur on
peut pas avoir des rapports sains entre
nous si on a des telles différences de
revenu et je vais donner un exemple qui
trouvait d'expériences personnelles
quand j'étais plus quand j'étais plus
jeune et je t'aime pas si riche que ça
j'étais étudiant à l'époque je sais ça
fait dix ans
puis il ya quelques il ya quelques
années je suis allé me balader emmène
par exemple ou en egypte et à l'époque
j'étais passé geste et j'étais bac pas
que j'avais un sac à dos j'étais un peu
postini bouger et non mais c'est la
crise il c'est le rapport à l'argent
c'est que quand il pas ils me voyaient
les personnes en inde où les personnes
en egypte même si elles étaient
quotidiens il voyait en fait marcher
devant le guichet automatique et donc
jeu on est tout le temps entouré de
personnes qui veulent nous demander de
l'argent des bakchichs les enfants qui
vous demande un stylo ou tuteurs les
occidentaux tout ça insupportable mais
en fait c'est totalement normal puisque
la différence d'argent est tellement
grande moi en tant qu étudiant à
l'université au niveau licence j'étais
capable de me pays billets d'avion en
inde du canada et de passer deux mois en
inde alors avec cet argent la prévenant
que je dépensais dans ce seul voyage
plus d'argent que ce qui me dit vous que
l'année où deux ans trois ans pour un
type de 30 ans 40 ans 50 ans qui pourra
jamais faire ça et donc on peut pas
avoir des rapports on peut pas avoir des
rapports sains dans un tel rapport
d'inégalité et eux c'est sûr qu'il sait
sur qui sait sur qui viennent vers moi
pas pour être mes amis viennent vers moi
pour mon fric si on était dans leur
situation frais évidemment la même chose
et donc là je reviens aux rapports entre
les hommes et les femmes est l'exemple
que tu donnes pour moi c'est le sait
c'est un symptôme et je ne juge pas la
femme la femme est elle peut en faire un
calcul à peu elle elle même développé
des sentiments elle sait pas c'est pas
s'est pas imposé mais messi mais cccc
c'est cette inégalité absolue entre
entre des personnes avec énormément de
force de même sont réduits et des élus
jeune femme qui fait que là il ya une
possibilité mais yann poster ou c'est
parce que ça s'inscrit dans une logique
c'est que c'est ce patriarcale où on a
sept représentations des vieux hommes
qui sont une représentation culturelle
et et
ça change des échanges ça dans
l'histoire ou presque et on a dévié fans
qui se paye des gigolos oui évidemment
il ya tout dans l'histoire
l'histoire de magna tout mais après ça
une fois qu'on a dit ça c'est il faut
regarder qu'est-ce qu'ils sont les
quelles sont les tendances et les
grandes généralités dans une société
pour en tirer des conclusions
sociopolitique parce que si on prend
tout le temps l'exemple de ces sur pau
c'est sûr qu'au canada par exemple
céline dion vous connaissent évidemment
céline dion c'est notre johnny hallyday
a nou sé lundi ont donc c'est une femme
elle est multimillionnaire c'est
l'artiste la plus célèbre du canada et
donc si on prend l'exemple de céline
dion on cache en fait toutes ces femmes
qui dans le milieu de la culture de
l'art du théâtre de la musique et cetera
au canada vivent des conditions beaucoup
plus difficile c'est bon sexuelle je
vends mes potes je parle même pas de
l'harcèlement sexuel mais oui évidemment
ces mots sexuelles violences sexuelles
mais aussi au niveau des revenus au
niveau de la capacité d'être vues
entendues à la radio la chanson que les
hommes s'il ya plein d'études de haut
niveau au québec qui montre les
inégalités dans le milieu de l'art mais
si on regarde juste céline dion on se
dira mais là c'est céline dion c'est la
preuve que les femmes les que les femmes
artistes peuvent être les plus riches
les plus les plus adulées les plus les
plus vénérés doudou mais c'est un
exemple c'est une exception c'est une
exception c'est l'arbre qui cache la
forêt nous nous on nous reproche
beaucoup d'avoir plus de 80% de dôme sur
notre chaîne
il faudrait faire un effort on essaye de
faire un effort sauf que on est à
l'image de la société c'est à dire que
comme les hommes ou les penseurs et
scientifiques alors certes y en a
d'autres oui mais ceux en charge c'est
comme tu l'a montré c'est beaucoup
d'hommes non oui donc nous notre
démarche tu me conseille de faire quoi
tu me conseille de faire plus de de
valorisation de faire d'eux de
sponsoriser plus les femmes tu penses tu
me conseilles quoi bah oui c'est
absolument là moi je suis si je suis
bien content mais
il faut remercier je vous remercie de
m'inviter et en plus vous m'invitez pour
parler d'un sujet film lisse mais il ya
certainement des femmes des féministes
qui vont regarder le truc en vain parce
que ça se passe mieux quand c'est un
homme qui
sait ce que ça passe mieux ça dépend
pour qui ça dit pas pourquoi mais c'est
sûr que des féministes qui vont dérober
là c'est encore francis dupuis déri
kippa ou du féminisme et c'est heureux
alors que tinqueux view a presque pas de
femmes et et ça le problème avec la sous
représentation des femmes dans dans les
médias ou dans votre émission par
exemple j'imagine que des arguments que
vous pourriez sortir c'est oui mon
premier moyenne à moins
d'un an seulement il ya moins d'auteurs
- intellectuelle mois des terrains que
d'hommes donc donc énergie de proportion
et puis vous pourriez me dire je sais
pas si c'est comme et vous pouvez me
dire on en est vite mais disent oui
moins souvent que les hommes elles
disaient plus à passer à passer dans les
médias et donc et donc et donc vous êtes
donc voilà c'est pas qu'on les a vite
passé qu'à vie c'est qu'elle vienne
passagers des gens tombent secondes sur
d'autres tribunes je sais pas si c'est
le cas ici est donc le problème avec ces
deux ces deux situations c'est que
c'est que c'est ccc ne sait ne c'est un
constat qui peut être vrai mais il ya un
côté fataliste bien côté d'eux une fois
qu'on a fait ce constat est ce qu on
fait juste des abats c'est comme ça et
donc en fait on finalement on qu'on
cautionne et on reproduit en fait cette
situation d' inégalités structurelles
système etc et et concrète ou est ce
qu'on se dit pas alors donc si elle s'y
lisent moins facile si elles acceptent
moins facilement devenir et s'il y en a
moins est-ce qu'on a une réunion
d'équipé et on essaie de développer des
stratégies pour les convaincre que ça va
être
ça va bien se passer pour elle est-ce
qu'on a est ce qu'on est capable de
trouver des relais qui vont nous aider à
convaincre des femmes de devenir et que
ça va bien se passer pour elle bien se
passer c'est à dire pas dire qu'il faut
pas leur poser des questions les mettre
en comptait 208 ou mais
c est se sentent plus vulnérables il
doit voir un moyen de les deux les de
les rassurer par exemple et deezer coup
de pouce mais je vais essayer je vais
essayer mais je vous avais envoyé
quelques noms mais bon après ça c'est
vous et je je je me rappelle même plus
lesquelles mais mes et
et se dire là il faut vraiment avoir une
stratégie dans les six prochains mois
comme on arrive à voir plus de femmes
parce que je reviens on a évoqué tout à
l'heure la question des femmes bavardent
qui est un mythe et qui est fallacieux
on a juste à si on regarde attentivement
sur les lieux de travail dans les dents
les groupes militants à l'universel moi
je le vois régulièrement ou dans les
études sociologiques ou à la télé les
femmes par le moins elle est le lourd de
la bande parce qu'on leur donne pas la
parole quand ils parlent elles se font
plus souvent interrompues et les hommes
parlent plus se font moins tu es roncq
et ça c'est un effet à la fois de notre
socialisation et du duel et de la
socialisation collective cdo qu'on a des
modèles d'hommes qui parle beaucoup qui
sont affirmatifs et qui ont toujours un
avis sur tout moi des fois je fais des
blagues avec ma conjointe et jusque là
sur un sujet sur lequel je ne connais
absolument rien je sors une théorie qui
n 10 mais comment tu sais sa plus belle
parce que je suis un homme voyant cc
c'est sûr que sur telle troupe était le
truc c'est comme ça que je bluffe
complètement et donc et donc et donc à
force de se faire interrompre de pas
être prise au sérieux de qu'on répète ce
qu'elles disent comme si elle n'avait
pas parlé puis qu'après ça c'est à
partir de nous qu'on conduit réduction
bay les femmes voient
ce qui arrive aux femmes quand elles
prennent la parole ou car elles ne
prennent pas la parole les ont moins de
modèles et elle même ont été ont été ont
subi des d'échec en échec l est
et c'est normal qu'elle ose moins c'est
évidemment des tendances générales il
peut avoir une femme qui tout à fait à
l'aise évidemment des femmes
journalistes des femmes politiciennes
des tutorats qui sont à l'aise de parler
en public je suis pas en train de dire
que c'est un cas général mais tout ça ça
joue dans le fait que au final il ya
moins de femmes il ya plus d'hommes et
s'il n'y a pas de une réflexion
volontaires pour assurer un pluralisme
et une diversité mais vous allez
simplement continuer à confirmer cette
tendance et donc est donc bon courage
j'te
je te pose une question d'internet que
jamais je vous redonne raid autre nom
wang demi soeur inquiète on attend et on
acceptera les nous un grand plaisir je
te pose une question on peut provoquer
alizée s'adonne pourquoi on se concentre
sur les violences faites aux femmes dans
nos médias sans mentionner les violences
psychologiques exercées par les femmes
et les infanticides dont ils sont le
plus souvent responsables donc déjà ses
ailes
c'est pour pat qui se demande tout le
temps comment je peux parler pendant
deux heures sans boire de l'eau donc
c'est la santé de mon ami pat
lui passe le bonjour oui absolument
[Musique]
je repose la question oui la question
définit ses rapports à la halle à la
violence que les banques et il se
concentre sur les violences faites aux
femmes dans nos médias sans mentionner
les violences psychologiques exercées
par les femmes et les infanticides dont
ils sont plus souvent responsables déjà
tu te trompes et ça doit elle oui
écoutez
on l'a dit là tout à l'heure c'est sais
je pensais
deux à trois femmes assassinées par
semaine en france par des conjoints des
ex-conjoints
ça c'est une violence physique
meurtrière
et là on évoque la violence
psychologique des femmes sur les hommes
est ce que c est ce qu est ce qu il faut
comprendre que les hommes n'exerce pas
de violence psychologique
on peut imaginer que ces femmes qui sont
assassinés un jour quand les scènes
qu'elles quittent leur conjoint elles en
ont bavé mais pendant des semaines des
mois des années de violence
psychologique de dénigrement d' insulte
de propos misogynes sexistes d'ordre de
commandement de 2
de propos qui ridiculise qui blessent
qui minent les cimes de soi et ça c'est
les femmes qui sont assassinés mais en
fait des femmes qui subissent de la
violence puisque le gic des hommes
de leur père de leur frère de leur
conjoint sur les revenus de ces terrains
attendez vous allez me faire croire que
les hommes on n'est pas que de violence
psychologique c'est complètement c'est
complètement absurde et dorsaz que
certaines nous dirons ce pas est ce que
tu as entendu saint brice et ils ont
elles ont peur ou et son minet dans la
dent lors dans leur confiance en eux
mêmes ou dans leur capacité ou de donc
et donc il faut arrêter cette idée que
d'un côté il y aurait les hommes qui ont
qui exercent une violence physique et de
l'autre côté les femmes qui auraient une
violence c'est qu'ils ont une source de
six mètres de la violence ou les femmes
exact mais aussi de la violence mais de
la violence la violence psychologique
premièrement
deuxièmement
deuxièmement c'est faux de dire qu'on ne
va pas de de la souffrance des hommes
puisque justement
le sujet ici c'est la question de la
fameuse le maître de la crise de la
masculinité il y en fait à peu près tous
les 2-3 ans dans le milieu d'édition
français ou aux etats-unis c'est la même
chose il ya un livre qui sort qui
prétend que les hommes sont en crise
dans les magazines il ya des dossiers
sur que la crise des sommes qu'elles
crise des hommes les hommes sont en
crise nos hommes sont en crise où sont
nos amis ce que sont devenus nos hommes
la fin des hommes
la fin de nos garçons qui s'occupe de
nos garçons les garçons et le désert des
garçons à l'école les pères divorcés les
pères qui perdent la garde des enfants
les pères souffrent les périodes et une
rechute et donc et des fois même dans
des magazines féminins et des magazines
féminins qui font des dossiers sur les
sommes en crise et donc de dire qu'on ne
prend pas en question le la souffrance
des hommes c'est faux c'est exactement
c'est exactement l'inversé que je crois
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que j'ai écrit
un livre pour déconstruire ce se met de
la crise de masculinité et on pense que
les hommes donc sauf psychologiquement
et du helmand et collectivement donc on
va arrêter avec ça quant aux un enfant
décide il faudrait vraiment vérifié mais
moi il me semble que les stades c'est
que j'ai vu c'est plus compliqué que ça
et en fait que les infanticides ça n'est
pas un parti ça dépend à quel âge mais
je pense que rapidement ce sont les ce
sont le l'homme qui est soit soit le
beau père soit le père soit le conjoint
ne ferait qu' responsable des enfants
qui qui qui donne ce qui tue la boue des
fois c'est une maltraitance plus ou
moins volontaires montre que le résultat
c'est la mort c'est la mort deux enfants
donc ça sûrs qu'ils quittent ce qui au
niveau des infanticides je serais
curieux de voir de voir des chefs lui
pressing mais en tout cas ce qui est
ce qu'il faut rappeler c'est que dans le
cas des féminicides les fameux
féministes dont on parle beaucoup
il ya des partis qui font pas je suis là
la mère de leur enfant et illiquides
toute la famille des fois il se hisse au
dessus après donc et ça c'est
éthiquement sais c'est un massacre de
masse qui arrivent beaucoup et souvent
de l'autre côté
vous fais remarquer que vous n'avez pas
terminé la question sur l'impact des
religions il ya des gens qui suivent
c'est très bien ils sont beaucoup l'un
oui après midi là ils sont beaucoup tant
mieux
[Musique]
l'impact des religions donc excusez moi
effectivement c'était parce qu'il y
avait plusieurs questions en même temps
dont la question foot non c'est pas
grave dont la question pourquoi j'avais
commencé à m'intéresser à ça et donc
j'ai passé 2 j'ai passé du temps à
parler de l'être sur une école
polytechnique demande énormément quand
j'étais plus jeune chez terra mais
effectivement donc quand j'ai commencé à
vouloir faire ce livre je me suis dit je
vais aller voir qu'est ce qui a été
écrit chez les historiens des
historiennes par exemple et ailleurs
dans la période plus contemporain
ailleurs sur la nature la crise de
masculinité et donc j'ai une chimie
c'est pas très intéressant mais j'ai mis
des mots clés dans des moteurs de
recherche de banques de données
d'articles universitaire de livres
d'articles de journaux et caetera et en
anglais en français c'est les deux
langues que je parle et j'ai mis crise
de masculinité ou men's health crisis ou
masculine ti kreis bord des équivalences
et là je suis tombée sur plein d'études
en histoire et sur l'actualité qui
disent soit qu'ils prennent au sérieux
le fait qu'une crise masque unités soit
qui disent on avait des discours de
crise de la masculinité est donc là je
suis arrivé pour le juste pour
l'occident
ça va jusqu'à la romantique maison de
façon plus concentré de la fin du moyen
âge à aujourd'hui de manière presque
permanente on peut entendre un discours
de crise de la masculinité au xvième
siècle dans la cour du roi d'angleterre
dans la cour du roi de france ou xviie
siècle au xviiie siècle pendant la
révolution française
de tous les côtés d'ailleurs au 19e
siècle en france ou en grande-bretagne
aux etats-unis très fort à la fin 19e
siècle aux états unis même le président
louvel telle époque des cabines crise la
virilité on écrit on a créé les boy
scouts of route pour pour faire face à
cette crise et on y laisse le sport
amateur aussi comme le football baseball
et tous
et prenant tout le xxème siècle à peu
près partout dans tous les pays on
pouvait entendre qu'ils avaient décru de
la sculpter et aujourd'hui j'ai trouvé
des des études en sociologie ou en
psychologie qu'ils disent de manière
plus ou moins critiques en fait on
entend cette idée qu'il ya une crise de
masse culte est partout en ce moment en
amérique latine partout en occident dans
les anciens pays du bloc de l'est
au japon en corée
dans les pays du maghreb en israël en
palestine
en afrique chez les wolofs partout en
afrique du sud et dans les trois grandes
religions ce qu'on appelle les trois
grandes religions de notre point de vue
est donc ça évidemment
c'est peut-être pas un argument qui va
convaincre les gens qu'ils sont
persuadés que les féministes domaine la
planète mais en tout cas pour moi ça
jette quand même un sacré doute sur le
fondement de ce discours de la crise de
masse culte et si on le trouve partout
tout le temps c'est quand même un peu
bizarre dans le genre dans des régimes
politiques des régimes économiques des
régions culturelles des régimes de haut
niveau du droit de la famille par
exemple sont totalement différents mais
dans tout ceci dans toutes ces
situations là on peut entendre le
discours de la crise de masculinité et
donc je m'inspire d'une historienne
américaine je détermine qui disait ça ça
démontre en fait qu'on ait pas face à un
vrai crise mais qu'on est face à un
discours de crise mais ça veut pas dire
que parce que la crise n'est pas réel
que le discours lui n'a pas d'impact
l'impact sur le réel on peut faire
quelque chose avec des discours d'une
fausse crise on peut être serré la
tension se présenter comme victime
dénigrer la cause de la crise appelait à
la mobilisation des autorités ou de
ressources pour nous pour nous en
prétendant qu'il ya une crise donc c'est
cette capacité à faire croire qu'ils en
crise apporte un discours de crise peut
avoir des effets politiques ou sociaux
ou économiques ou culturels très
important et dans les religions les
études que j'ai vu sur 7 sur cette
question disent dans l'it ce qu'on peut
appeler les trois grandes religions
c'est notre point de vue évidemment il
ya le plus de clients bon en tout cas
pour deux points de vue de l'occident
dont on parle du christianisme judaïsme
et de l'islam
j'ai trouvé des études qui disent de
manière plus ou moins critique que leurs
hommes de leurs communautés sont en
crise de la masculinité il ya
différentes manières de le formuler et
il ya différentes solutions je vais
parler rapidement des chrétiens sous
permettait donc en tout temps
déjà la fin du 19e siècle il y avait des
mouvements
chrétien socialiste aux états unis ça
peut paraître bizarre quand les gens
pensent que les sociétés sont hâtés mais
y avait deux du socialisme chrétiens fn
neuvième siècle aux états unis et ils
ont développé une idéologie qui
s'appelle qui socialiste et chrétien ou
tord oui mais il ya eu 100 ans en france
ou s'il a au 19e siècle l'idée que jésus
était du côté des barricades juste une
faute et des pauvres
et que le vrai message de jésus c'est un
message d'égalité contre contre contre
les élites contre contre les grands
prêtres contre les riches contre la
décadence liés à la richesse c'est une
logique de prophètes les prophètes
antisocialisme je
parle de la fin du début de neuvième
siècle en europe c'est une logique de
prophètes dans le sens biblique du terme
c'est à dire le prophète c'est celui qui
marche dans la rue et dénonce les
inégalités de la société ils disent que
ces inégalités elles sont la faute des
grands prêtres qui sont corrompus qui
sont dans le luxe alors que le peuple
n'a rien ou des princes ou des rois de
l'aristocratie c'est ça les prophètes et
d'ailleurs ils sont ils sont ils sont
ils sont exécutés parce qu'ils disent et
donc les socialistes révolutionnaires du
début du 19e siècle il y en avait qui
est écrite c'est dans cet esprit-là un
esprit contre contre le betis quand un
contre contre la richesse de de l'église
puis on essaie tout au 20e siècle la
théologie de la libération cdd prête
révolutionnaire marxiste en fait bref
je suis pas chrétien je suis athée mais
c'est juste c'est juste pour presser et
donc à la fin du 19e siècle il y a
il y a il y a donc des socialistes
chrétiens aux états unis qui disent
qu'il ya une crise de masculinité et il
propose comme solution l'idéologie de ce
qu'ils appellent le musclor
musclor christianisme c'est à dire le
christianisme musculaire et ils vont
présenter une image de jésus qui connaît
jésus qui c'est noir le blanc celui qui
la barque jésus jésus le jésus le jésus
de la bible on sait la bible de la bd
chrétienne série des juifs oui bien
qu'elle était imprimé en europe où jésus
les blancs prime aux états unis à la fin
de neuvième siècle donc les blancs c'est
sûr qu'il est blanc et il a probablement
une barbe il s'est radicalisé et
il a été crucifié et donc les les
musclor cruciaux nous sommes dit oui
jésus est amour mais il n'est pas que
douceur et les forces c'est un homme
viril et ils vont dire la preuve c'est
qu'il a il a survécu à la tentation la
résister à la tentation il a été 40
jours dans le désert il a survécu et en
plus il s'est même fait crucifier il a
souffert 7 cette douleur partie
s'apprend absolue il a porté sa croix et
donc qu'est-ce qu'ils organisent les
socialistes chrétiens égyptiens cause 2
me pour lutter contre ce qu'il pensait
être une crise de masse culte et des
retraites des retraites entre sommes
chrétiens et donc ils se retrouvent le
week-end houleux la semaine dans la
forêt à chasser ensemble joue de la
guitare et prier jésus et se re
viriliser ce qu'on a encore aujourd'hui
en france et aux états unis dans des
dangers dans des réseaux chrétiens
catholiques et protestants aux états
unis en france vous avez ça vu comment
il dit qu'il est gay
ça c'est ça aussi c'est lié à la
séquence qualifie tout c'est ridicule et
c'est aussi lié à la conception de la
crise au mas culte et qui est le
discours la crise au masculin est
homophobe mais met donc donc chez les
chrétiens chez les catholiques chez les
protestants ou si vous avez jusqu'à
aujourd'hui des des autorités
religieuses ou des leaders religieux qui
vont dire la virilité est en crise qui
vont dire les femmes prennent trop de
place dans les paroisses chrétiennes
catholique l influence trop l'église
faut faire quand même il enfume du bon
comme on dit et et donc il faut
revaloriser viriliser l'homme critiquent
catholique lui redonner le sens de
qu'est ce qu'être un homme et un père
évidemment parce qu'ils ont une
conception très patriarcale le chef de
famille le conjoint quitte en charge et
sous prétexte qu'ils auraient une crise
de masculinité pas juste dans
l'assistance général mais même dans
l'église catholique il dans l'île et
chez les communautés chrétiennes je le
fais plus rapidement pour les les juifs
et les îles les musulmans oui mais c'est
parce que si je connais moins
je connais moins
c'est surtout la religion musulmane que
je connais moins mais chez les juifs que
j'ai retrouvé des discours de crise de
masques sculptés en israël mais aussi
surtout en fait aux états unis dans les
communautés juives américaines chez les
ch et les jeunes garçons ou des adultes
des hommes prestement juifs disent nos
jeunes hommes sont en crise mais sculpté
ils ont plus modèles masculins il ya
trop d flows du féminin aux états unis
et dans les communautés juives et
il faut vraiment faire quelque chose
c'est inadmissible les femmes prennent
trop de place et chez des rats est une
des premières rabin donc le féminin de
rabbins une des premières rabin à
cleveland aux états unis ont réagi à ce
type de discours en disant
en disant non non ça va pas du tout là
on fait quand tout était pour les hommes
personnes disaient qu'ils avaient une
crise de la féminité ou que les femmes
juives est en crise mais maintenant que
les hommes pensent que les femmes
avancent vers plus d'égalité dans la
communauté juive ont dit qu'une crise de
masculinité asie c'est simplement une
avancée vers l'égalité plus de justice
et en tant que juifs et juive nous
devrions être pour que dans nos
communautés y ait plus d'égalité de
justice et donc les hommes doivent
arrêter de prétendre qu'il les aimait
sculpté plutôt ce recul de rabin
française en france oui il y avait et on
va taxer les symptômes de la
féminisation de la société pour l'homme
mais met donc vous avez ça chez la
communauté juive aux états unis et ses
essais des articles sur la crise de la
masculinité des jeunes juifs dans des
dans des magazines de la communauté
juive aux états unis qui par ailleurs
dix admettent que tendanciellement de
manière générale les la communauté juive
aux etats-unis cédées au frenchie il
s'en tire mieux économiquement
professionnellement que lors que la
majorité des américains les américaines
est totalement fou ce qui est totalement
faux en tout cas cessé ces jeunes ces
jeunes ces jeunes juifs qui sont dans
des écoles qui sont dans des classes
plutôt privilégié en fait de prétendre
qu'ils sont en crise et est absurde
selon la règle dans questions parce
qu'elles disent non ils viennent de
milieux favorisés ils ont prise en fait
ils ont pas de problème c'est juste
qu'ils ont une sorte d'obsession sur eux
sur les femmes et le fait que les femmes
puissent être leur égal parce que dans
le discours de la crise de masques
dégâts cette obsession que l'égalité est
un problème pour les hommes et pour la
masculinité et puis voilà et puis pour
l'islam comme j'ai dis je je maîtrise je
maîtrise moins 7 les références
théologiques et la logique spirituel
mais j'ai trouvé là aussi c'est la
référence cédant aidants et dans le
livre des études du point de vue de
l'islam par départ des musulmans qui
disent aussi que dans le monde musulman
il y aussi des crise de la masculinité
et qui s'éteint et qu'il faut et en fait
revaloriser la masculinité musulmane
mais je terme et qu'elle pendant
quelques jours sur la question de
la crise de la masculinité chez les
musulmans pour montrer aussi là
l'élasticité de ce discours de crise de
la masse culte et qui peut être usé de
pouvait tout et son contraire
dans les perspectives restent et c'était
islamophobe qui présente en fait l'islam
ou les musulmans comme une menace pour
l'occident on va utiliser le discours de
la crise de maturité pourri pour
expliquer pourquoi pourquoi il ya cette
menace donc dans new york times le
washington post je me trompe pas ça
aussi c est référencée dans le livre
mais ça vient en fait d'une étude de
suan phlu dit un autre livre qu'elle
écrit qui s'appelle tireur green qui
malheureusement n'a pas été traduit en
français qui sur le post 11 septembre
devenu pour montrer comment on fait tout
un discours de crise de la masculinité
de dinde fumée s'est développée après le
11 septembre et de revalorisation de 1
sur 2 d'ethos masculin viril après l'on
s'attend donc l'attaquant durant
l'attaqué aérienne en septembre 2001
contre les états unis il va y avoir des
textes qui vont dire en fait on sait
pourquoi on a été attaquée c'est parce
qu'en fait il ya une crise de la
masculinité dans les communautés
musulmanes et que ses hommes en fait
sont au chômage et parce qu'ils sont au
chômage ne peuvent pas se réaliser en
tant que père et en tant que conjoint
avoir des relations sexuelles avant une
famille ecce terra est apparemment mais
je ne savais pas à l'époque mais
apparemment quand les hommes sont en
crise d'identité ils détournent des
avions il lance dans des buildings toi
et je sais pas s'il s'en est ému après
mais en tout cas et on va reprendre ce
discours pour expliquer chez certains
sociologues par exemple qu'on appuie le
printemps arabe en 2000 en 2011 donc
plutôt que de trouver des explications
pour sociopolitique plus fine et de
comprendre la situation en tunisie ou en
egypte ou en syrie de se dire on veut
dire moi ça c'est une expression de la
crise de la masculinité des jeunes
hommes arabes qui en fait à 18 20 ans
sont au chômage qui est un gros problème
de chômage dans ces pays et donc il ne
se réalisent pas comment mais
apparemment qu'on se réalisent pas
comment mais comment quand on peut plus
détourné des avions parce que maintenant
il est de moins de sécurité dont on
renverse
moubarak et ben ali et on fait la guerre
en fait on déclenche une guerre civile
en syrie toi donc c'est une sorte de 2
de de 10,17 crise damas culte et qui
sert expliqué n'importe quel type de
phénomène et puis pour continuer sur la
menace de l'islam on retrouve dans les
réseaux d'extrême droite et chez des
auteurs comme eric zemmour que
évidemment vous connaissez j'ai publié
un livre en 2006 qui défend la thèse
qu'il y ait une crise de la masculinité
en france et que les hommes français
peuvent plus dragué si on m'invite tu
viens non et je le mettrais ce pas du
tout et hold et radicalisée jeu on voit
jamais arriver à le dire et de qualité
de toute façon un constat d'échec non
mais c'est que je crois que je crois que
des cadets qui a des débats et des
discussions qui n'ont pas lieu d'être
qui n'ont aucun intérêt parce qu'en fait
les parties ne s'est pas donné c'est pas
de dialoguer de lits de discuter et et
et
émaux moi j'ai pas envie de participer à
sa façon à son auto promotion à ça à sa
promotion jusque par exemple je
soignerai pas discuter avec moi je m'en
fous complètement de façon j'aime bosser
c'est pas c'est pas quelqu'un avec qui
et avec qui mais qu'il faut discuter il
ne faut pas discuter avec lui il faut
pas l'écouter il faut pas le comprendre
à le comprendre oui
parce que je sais que si tu fais pas ce
que parce que si tu discutes pas un
cubain en lice et lille vont les côtes
moi j'ai lu ses livres je les côtes est
donc dans ce livre où il prétend qu'il
ya une crise de la masculinité en france
il il commence en disant les hommes ne
peuvent plus draguer
il il continue en disant la preuve qu'il
est une crise de la masculinité en
france c'est en étant 2006 il dit sait
on à quelle heure regarder l'équipe de
foot de 2006 française ils disent les
hommes pour des boucles d'oreilles ça
c'est une preuve irréfutable n'est ce
pas il est maintenant il ne joue plus
individuellement ils se font des passes
à très féminin ça se faire dépasser
jouer en équipe soit et donc ça c'est la
preuve de la féminisation de l'équipe de
france et ils ont comme conjointe des
mannequin androgyne des femmes androgyne
qui sont désignés en fait par des
designers homosexuels tout ça c'est
zemmour qui dit ça se sait donc est donc
là il ya une sorte de foucque tu es donc
là il ya une sorte de complot
dans la tête 2 est mort entre le
dézinguer homosexuels les femmes la
féminisation de la société mais il
continue il finit avec évidemment
la menace de l'islam parce que c est
mort et il dit en écho vraiment à ce que
10 des groupes vraiment de white se
promet 6-2 suprémacistes blancs
néo nazis en scandinavie ailleurs il dit
en fait l'occident l'homme occidental
l'homme blanc a été castré dévirilisé
parler entre eux par les féministes des
années 60 et par l'automatisation du
travail et du terrain et donc comme il
est castré dévirilisé il n'est plus
capable comme l'ancien vikings de
défendre le territoire de défendre
l'occident de défendre les femmes de
défendre sa famille de défendre ses
enfants face à la menace que représente
ce que zemmour va appeler le jeune le
jeune garçon arabe le jeune garçon des
[__] jeu par la fois jme république
exactement ce qu'il dit mais c'est cette
espèce de mythe du jeune homme aram qui
en fait le violeur et l'agresseur et
l'envahisseur
qu'on n'arrête pas arrêté et donc
zemmour explique ce problème par la
crise de la masculinité chez l'homme
français l'homme français en guise de
l'imaginaire un breton ou un picard ou
je ne sais pas en quoi il est blanche
poser mon jeu mais j'aime bien et il a
un prénom français je ne crois pas ce
que zemmour accorde beaucoup
d'importance au prénom même s'il s'est
tellement mai
donc pour moi qui s'appelle
pierre dupont et
met donc ce fameux jeune homme aram qui
lui est hyper hyper viril et violeurs
potentiels ben c'est la même image qu'on
avait aux états unis avec l'ancien
esclave afro-américains qui est un
violeur qu'il faut les prendre et lynché
en fait parce que c'est un violeur
potentiel c'est toujours cette idée en
fait de d'une sorte de
guerre entre les races ou l'ange hui et
et l'agression sexuelle est où là la
menace est et cette virilité mais qui en
fait qui achève demain des des anges
juifs des mentions qui sont pas ceux la
cdc des enjeux de contrôle de ressources
de contrôle de territoires d'exclusion
de l'eau et cetera je te pose une
question qui n'a rien à voir avec le
sujet juste pour ressaisir la ligne
rouge avait isolé une question
si vous états unis un jour ils
élisent un musulman oui il va prêter
serment sur quoi parce qu'une god we
trust il prête serment sur la bible aux
états unis je te pose la question est ce
que tu es dans wii mais je suis pas
arrêté pour lui il va prêter serment sur
le coran mais je n'ai aucune idée en
fait ça non mais en fait de toute façon
ça n'a aucune importance parce que je
veux pas te faire de la peine mais en
fait le dieu des chrétiens le dieu des
jeux effet le dieu des musulmans c'est
le même dieu
et donc
bah en fait c'est ça la théorie c'est
que c'est le même dieu sait juste que il
interprète un peu différemment ou ou cd
étape en fait dans le mais le dieu le
dieu des juifs va devenir le dieu des
chrétiens et le et ce premier du des
jeux devient aussi le dieu des musulmans
avec mahomet pour les musulmans et jésus
pour pour les chrétiens mais c'est le
même dieu bon j'ai retrouvé la question
merci
j'en ai assez entendu personnellement il
a tout dit lorsqu'il a expliqué pourquoi
il a démarré ses recherches il était
innervé ségalen biais idéologique et
personnelle majeur mais il a aucune
objectivité
oui oui c'est sûr que c'est toujours
mieux de travailler sur des trucs qui
nous qui ne touchent pas pour lesquels
on n'a pas de réaction affective et qui
vous qu'on n'a pas de passion je sais
pas vraiment qui fait ce genre de
travail mais et j'imagine que la
personne qui écrit
ce message elle n'est pas énervé par mon
commentaire et objective et ils n'ont
passionnés et totalement raisonnable
donc c'est un commentaire intéressant
effectivement oui mais non moi je trouve
que c'est beaucoup plus intéressant de
travailler sur des sujets sur lesquels
on est passionné de façon parce que ça
nous énerve et on a envie de comprendre
de plus qu'est ce qui nous énerve ou
parce qu on aime soit on aime si on peut
dire ce sujet on a envie de le
développer mais l'énervement par rapport
à un sujet empêche pas du tout un
travail rigoureux que ça vous fait en
total désaccord avec ce que j'ai fait
j'ai trouvé que
évidemment je suis pas objectif c'est
vraiment un des arguments qu'on me qu'on
me lance à la figure
quand on sait en plus que je suis
rattaché un issu de recherches et
d'études féministes et de rabais là on
sait bien c'est c'est une approche
féministe mais le
mais le travail c'est le travail que que
les sociologues et politologues
les anthropologues des psychologues au
niveau de la recherche font c'est
essayer de comprendre des choses est
dans une démarche de rigueur c'est ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure je lire des
historiens d'historienne gelé lire
des personnes avec qui j'étais
absolument pas d'accord zemmour année
soral vie groupe des groupes religieux
j'écoutais des vidéos j'ai lu des livres
j'ai dû des blogs ça a été les
rencontres non pas du tout parce que
j'ai pas envie de rencontrer j'ai envie
de la rencontrer
mais parce que je considère que c'est
des personnes tant que saic est
dangereuse et néfaste et avec lesquels
je n'ai aucune aucune affinité pour que
je demande encore comment tu veux
réconcilier
ses différentes communautés d égalité
réconciliation c'est ça je veux pas dire
est que bert on vous conseille bonjour
vu beaucoup assure alain rousset c'est
pourquoi on serait considérer sauf si tu
dis non mais les changements arrêtés se
comprendre mais il faut arrêter mais il
faut pas il faut arrêter avec ça c'est
pas comme ça que ça fonctionne la
société
cas il ya des choses comme les cahiers
des citoyens des sociétés comme les
nôtres qui sont totalement inégalitaire
qui sont fondamentalement inégalitaire
ça veut dire qu'il ya des intérêts non
seulement les différents mais opposé qui
sont en contradiction il ya des gens qui
défendent tel intérêt des gens qui
défendent l intérêt des gens qui
défendent l opposition et l opposition
et ce sont des positions qui sont
irréconciliables il faut pas il faut
arrêter de penser que tout peut se
dissoudre autour d'un verre de scotch
entre gentlemen dans un club bigouden le
bellec ou un barbecue ou à manger du
tofu ou je sais pas trop quoi il ya des
positions qui ne sont qu ils ne sont pas
des conciliables et moi je pense je ne
considère pas du tout qu'on a à discuter
avec tout le monde c'est absurde ce sont
peut pas durer quand même pas débattre
pourquoi pourquoi débattre avec ces gens
là
il s'était il en va cria mais ça c'est
l'ascenseur où c'est le refus de la
liberté d'expression je te laisse pas
tout seul la censure et la liberté
d'expression les départements de 2 de
physique à l'université j'imagine qu'ils
arrivent est pas des gens qui pensent
que la terre est plate ou ou où les
départements tu fais pour des
radicaliser des gens qui pensent que la
terre est plate si tu n'en fais pas
visité dit honnêtement les gens dont qui
pensent que la terre est plate c'est
vraiment le dernier des soucis là c'est
ça c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment pas très exigeant qui
trouve les plâtres en plus ils sont gros
des foyers des fois ils veulent aller
dans l'espace pour essayer de prouver
que la terre est plate c'est vraiment le
truc le plus rigolo gouaille son coup
tout et les anti vaccin c'est l'exemple
comme un autre comment tu fais pour des
radicaliser les anti vaccins situent les
emmène pas avoir un service
d'épidémiologie où tu lui fait
rencontrer un épidémiologiste tu tu fais
comment mais premièrement je moi je vous
mets invité pour parler l'examen sprint
et max âgés moi je suis vacciné mais je
ne suis pas médecin je suis pas je vais
pas commencer je peux pas gérer tous vos
problèmes donc c'est aussi des problèmes
c'est ce qu'une sortie vaccin n'a du
coup oui oui mais la ville
il reste libre est quoi si je suis
chanceux une vingtaine d'années habib
l'avant que moi j'ai été vacciné
j'aimerais vraiment les pieds les autres
les autres gérants du problème qui ont
compris les ordres de vaccins sais pas
je veux pas tout gérer mais en tout cas
ce qui est clair c'est que des gens
comme
comme comme ceux dont on parle
en fait c'est fou cette idée les gens
reviennent tout le temps avec cette
question est ce que est ce que tu
débattrait avec machin est ce que tu te
dis que tu es avec machin mais pourquoi
on discuterait lors des batteries avec
avec tous ces gens avec avec lesquels on
a des idées fondamentalement différente
opposé contreforts nous ne défendons pas
les intérêts les mêmes d'intérêt ne
parlons pas du même lieu et je reviens à
cette idée c'est que nous sommes dans
des sociétés fondamentalement
inégalitaire injuste avec des positions
différentes et les gens qui défendent
cette position de cette position ils
n'ont pas la même conception du monde
n'ont pas la même vision du monde et ça
va pas se résoudre dans un débat entre
jean chômage avec la force du meilleur
argument c'est pas comme ça que ça me
touche suivez les utilisent dans leur
fit filter 2 leur bulle du filtre sans
jamais pouvoir le retournement c'est ça
mais je veux pas leur tendre la main
you ils veulent pas tendre la main non
plus il insulte les gens ils étaient les
items des discours haineux il avait géré
donc pas ce que je peux te passer la
question ce qui n'est pas une question
c'est un commentaire d'un internaute et
la question c'est pourquoi tu te fais
insulter tout le temps pourquoi on
essaye de diviser pour qu'on essaie de
te cordiaux risée quand on a fait la
première interview avec toi on s'est
pris un torrent de merde de extrême
droite qui tend mettait plein la tête
qui traitait tous les noms d'oiseaux
possibles imaginables
d'ailleurs pour renforcer je pense la
masculinité
là il ya un commentaire qui dit cette
interview est pitoyable tu prends
n'importe quel type en première année de
sociaux il te sort la même salade
affligeant oui c'est quoi ça
ben évidemment scellier scellier
scellier au fait c'est lié au fait que
je sois professeur d'anglais à chaque
fois qu'on n'est pas d'accord avec
universitaire on va ridiculiser le fait
que en tant qu'universitaire il dit
quelque chose d'aussi ridicule donc ça
c'est le truc de base là on entend ça
tout le temps évidemment et c'est
intéressant parce qu'en fait les
personnes qui sont pas d'accord avec ce
que j'ai sur l'abstentionniste visa
c'est ridicule en tant qu'universitaire
il est vraiment pitoyable budgétaire s
est pas possible qu un anniversaire de
ce quelque chose comme ça sur
l'abstention quand je dis quelque chose
sur les black blocs où j'ai fait des
recherches les black blocks ont dit
rasséréné quelque anniversaire d'un
quand j'ai quelque chose sur la police
au delà c'est le culte universel et ceci
sur la police et quand j'ai quelque
chose sur la crise de la masculinité sur
lequel j'ai travaillé pendant des années
que j'ai lu des dizaines de livres
d'aidés des centaines d'articles que
j'ai épluché les trucages étaient rendus
assez ridicule un universitaire tu dois
donc apparemment ces gens la trouvent
que dit qu'ils sont pas d'accord avec un
anniversaire est ok l'université a fait
pas son boulot c'est tant mieux pour eux
c'est l'envié de bien des mains beaucoup
plus simple et je les envie en fait
c'est c'est eh oh merde bref c'est ils
s'en foutent de mots de cette façon là
et et après ça il ya effectivement
toujours justes donc là ça dépend des
sujets
évidemment quand c'est sur la police ou
les black blocks et huit rebelles le
chef un anarchiste nef infantile qui
manque de maturité et qui sait pas ce
qu'il dit est
et quand c'est sur leur camp c'est sur
la crise de la masculinité perspective
proof ministre ben là évidemment c'est
l'attaqué et les attaques j'ai très
souvent vivement ni danser c'est que
selon les préférences sexuelles le fait
que j'aie des bouts de rei on m'a
traitée au québec est une expression qui
est que j'adore qui je suis un homme
vagin par exemple et donc c'est toujours
une fin pour moi j'ai jamais compris ce
que ça veut dire exactement où vivent
aussi les insultes basses et des
insultes évidemment et puis s'assied ou
s'il ya c'est très drôle le pcsi c est
donc c'est moi je trouve moi je les
garde en fait je les archives c'est là
dessus parce qu'en fait c'est un
matériel extra ordinaire pour voir en
fait là l'état d'esprit la logique les
références les es q qu'est ce que ça
vient pis si bas c'est l'idée que c'est
les femmes qui paissaient simek un vrai
en eps debout pour éteindre les feux on
est au milieu du rhône et au milieu de
la savane et on est allé les feux comme
ça de bouge-toi de face à l'adversité et
ou même autres qui courent vers nous
mais mais non mais ça sera enfin 110 110
110 vraiment beaucoup sur justement ce
que j'analyse est ce que je trouve que
c'est peut-être cet imaginaire aux
brivistes viriliste
pathétique en fait qui manque
complètement de de subtilité de nuances
et qui commet comme on le dit de façon
vulgaire qui qui qui qui elle sakic est
là qu elle a à la place du cerveau ils
pensent vraiment avec sa queue alors il
ya une question de martial qui dit je
fais un peu exprès pas poser des
questions un peu un peu chelou pourquoi
on n'a pas un mannequin avec un
syndicaliste de la cgt
et je ne comprends absolument pas de
commentaire parce qu'on prend pas non
plus dans l'axé une question pourquoi on
n'a pas un mannequin avec un simple
pourquoi un jeune qui ne sort pas avec
un syndicaliste cgt c'est des questions
polion cd question de l'influencé des
questions quoi jourdas déjà donné la
réponse d'ailleurs
ça c'est encore des questions il ya
appliqué vous un peu
et
on va on va on va revenir sur notre
interview comprendre les questions des
internautes après
je reviens aux préconisations
comment on fait vraiment pour améliorer
ça quand on voit le discours politique
qui est très volontaire d'un côté mais
qui a qui est relativement
sous-entendu à l'étranger quand on voit
la france continué de faire des
partenariats avec l'arabie saoudite
qui analysent
forcément les milliards de dollars en
jeu dans la vente d'armements l'armement
alors que l'arabie saoudite lapide les
femmes les paons leur coupe la tête et
fait la guerre au yémen
fellag on aime bien entendu en france on
connais bien c'est un sujet où vous les
français n'aiment pas du moins les
médias français n'aiment pas trop vers
le mas canadien pas tellement plus non
plus ça en commun et donc il m'a fait
perdre mon fils donc l'arabie saoudite
qui pend qui flagelle les femmes dès
qu'il ya une femme féministe couvait un
peu sa gueule en taule
ils disent que le féministe ils ont fait
une annonce sur internet sont faits ils
sont rattrapés avec une vidéo comme quoi
les féministes étaient des criminels
terroristes et j'en passe
c'est pas que c'est pas un peu et donc
là tu as les supporters de foot qui dit
qu'ils disaient marine chapa bon écoute
tu fais ta malines mais à côté de ça on
continue de fricoter avec les saoudiens
il faut faire quoi il faut faire le même
lot prendre ton point de vue c'est à
dire là il discute plus avec ces gens là
mais quand même on les arbres
on arrête de les vendre et pas les
vendre il faut faire quoi continuer à
leur parler il ya une belle salman après
avoir coupé un journaliste en morceaux
essaie de se racheter une conscience sur
le pavé de l'échiquier mondial de la
communication publique en disant voilà
maintenant comprenez on a une société un
peu archaïque maintenant les femmes
maintenant elles peuvent conduire vous
voyez pas le progrès mais quand on voit
que l'arabie saoudite qui est une
commission pour le droit des femmes
il ya que des mecs à l'intérieur qu'est
ce qu'on fait cela était préconisations
effective si ce soir on doit faire la
révolution pour les femmes nous les
hommes on fait quoi
donc
deux choses se fait volontairement
candide oui
et
je me faire volontairement nuancé et
donc la première chose c'est sur
l'arabie saoudite j'ai aucune des deux
façons en train de faire tourner au
vagin de toute façon mon opus et le pcsi
de toute façon de toute façon évidemment
mon avis sur l'art et bissau
d'établissement au corps et pourtant ce
ne sera jamais aucune aucune décision au
prix de ces que nous versons lobbies
arabies ne sais pas du tout si ça fait
genre à 150 mm ce n'est absolument pas
dû me zerby c'est juste un fait objectif
les décisions gouvernementales
économique financière les alliances
militaires tutorat par rapport à
l'arabie saoudite et de l'occident des
états occidentaux elles sont totalement
imbriquée dans des noues 2 2
d'intérêt commun et date depuis
très longtemps de ses commence pas
aujourd'hui et
et ça remonte même avant la première
guerre en afghanistan où l'union
soviétique s'est embourbée en
afghanistan ou l'arabie saoudite
s'étaient en fait l'allié des etats-unis
contre l'union celui de ces camps et
rabih saoudite et où les états unis en
fait sacrifier totalement le droit des
femmes en arabie saoudite pardon le
droit des femmes en afghanistan pour
mieux combattre ce qu'on appelait
évidemment le péril rouge dans des
stratégies de l'endiguement et donc et
donc bref je serai pas l'histoire m'a
gardé guerre en afghanistan multiples
guerre en afghanistan mais l'arabie
saoudite était déjà une ali on sait très
bien l'arabie saoudite était un dit une
des chevilles ouvrières de cette de ce
réseau d'alliances et évidemment oussama
ben laden et qui était qui était lié à
l'arabie saoudite qui a apprécié la il a
viré soeur aujourd'hui la main de son
maître exactement mais mais ce qu'on a
parce que les fameux talibans en
afghanistan ils ont pris leurs modèles
de de l'arabie saoudite et ils ont été
pendant quelques années les alliés des
etats-unis qu'ils étaient invités à
l'elysée et à éviter aux etats-unis les
talibans jusqu'à ce qu'on décide qu'en
fait si ils étaient nos élites et les
pires barbare de l'humanité et donc sur
ces questions de de géostratégie et
d'alliances et du terrain je peux bien
dire qu'il faudrait pas qu'on fasse ceci
vous qu'on fasse cela c'est pas très
important sur ce que les des hommes peut
faire
dans la lutte dans la lutte dans les
luttes féministes ça dépend vraiment il
ya différentes options
les féministes ont réfléchi aussi ont
différentes demandes par rapport aux
sommes donc ça dépend aussi à quel
féministes ou à quelle femme on parle ou
avec qui ont été en relation
il y a mais je dirais avant de commencer
je dirais
c'est revient au débat tout à l'heure
sur la question de la longue liste est
par définition et c'est vrai pour
d'autres types de lutte
le d'immenses passion lutte pour
l'égalité lutte pour la dignité lutte
pour la justice lutte pour la sécurité
ou c'est à dire ne pas être toujours se
sentir menacés et éventuellement blesser
et tuer
c'est leur lutte est aussi la doutre
c'est avant tout la leur non il faut pas
penser que c'est qu'on est con et dans
une potion égal dans cette lutte c'est
vraiment c'est leur lutte et
etc leurs analyses ne sont pas tous
d'accord entre elles elles ont
différentes priorités différentes
stratégies différentes
analyses de la situation elle
s'engueulent des fois ne se parlent plus
ils se
réconcilient des foisons des
convergences des foisons pas de
concurrent facebook comme des prix comme
celui mais qui comme dans tous les
mouvements sociaux un nouveau syndicat
le mouvement étudiant mouvement maîtres
même des jeux les jaunes mouvement
le mouvement des sans-terre mouvement
alter ce qu'on avait le mouvement
altermondialiste mouvement anarchiste
donc il ya tout le temps des scissions
différents points de vue d'édition de
sur les priorités la notion d'efficacité
est qu au moyen long terme et du terrain
et puis le la lutte féministe elle a
ceci de particulier par rapport à
d'autres luttes que est ce que je dis
c'est passé c'est pas très original mais
qui en fait surtout évidemment dans les
rapports hétérosexuels mais aussi dans
la famille qu'il y ait en fait un lien
organique et éventuellement
émotif effectifs amoureux et sexuel
entre les deux camps et et skie pas vrai
par exemple entre l'employé et son
patron entre un esclave est un maître
antoine riboud
entre entre nous il ya on ne vit pensons
et mais n'importe quel homme à ma
connaissance est venu au monde par une
femme la mère et
puis les hommes et et puis donc ont
grandi dans des familles sont dans les
familles et puis après ça sont
hétérosexuels on va avoir des rapports
interpersonnels avec une ou des femmes
au cours de notre vie et donc ça ça crie
un rapport très particulier dans ses
noces dans cette danse et dans ses
rapports dans ses rapports politiques
dans ces rapports sociaux dans ses
rapports de force dansez dansez dans
cette lutte politique qui fait que les
hommes on peut évidemment jouer un des
rôles ou des rôles où on peut essayer
des choses pour amoindrir nos privilèges
ne pouvoir nos avantages notre
pourquoi tu dis à vous drire c'est
peut-être les c'est est renforcée
d'autres choses plus importantes nom
wii est développé d'autres manières
d'autres manières d'être des manières
d'être plus plus égalitaire qui acquit
et qui permettent ou qu'ils accordent ou
qui ne ce qui ne se braque pas comme des
femmes à la longue ça commence par quoi
les attitudes parcours oui mais là on
est on est dans l'air on est même dans
la banalité du quotidien mais c'est
celle et hachez la langue c'est des cdc
les perceptions c'est les attentes c'est
la manière d'exprimer le désir d'écouter
ce que l'autre a dit à dire d'être
capable d'exprimer ce que nous ce que
l'on pense donc c'est vraiment rien de
très très très sophistiquée et puis
quand il faut qu'on arrête d'être gagné
ca c
rires la porte à une femme lui met
souvent tout la faire marcher du côté du
mur pas du côté du trottoir parce qu'on
sait jamais si elle tombe dans trottoirs
et chaussées talent ou ça c'est très
british oui oui mais quand on boit trop
nous c'est des fois on tombe un bout de
trottoir mais non mais c'est ça c'est
dit ça c'est dit ça c'est des questions
c'est dire quand même sur internet dit
oui je sais mais excuse moi exerçait
comme ça ça va pas être très gentil mais
ça pour moi c'est d'y céder sous
problème là on est vraiment pas et ça
revient tout le temps cette question de
la galanterie c'est je pense pas que
c'est ça on est obligées de la poussière
voilà tu la pause et jeté le pendu c'est
pour moi c'est passé c'est pas des
[Musique]
cds fou problème c'est un peu des faux
problème et s'est dressé dans les
interactions quotidiennes ici une femme
veut pas qu'on exprime des jo de
galanterie
la galanterie sait pas quand même c'est
quand même pas d'imposer quelque chose
que la femme veut pas se lancer plus de
la galanterie c'est ça ressemble plus à
du harcèlement non donc si on égale en
respect la limite que nous que nous pose
la femme avec qui on est ou avec qui on
est en interaction et puis si on a envie
d'essayer d'être galant puis elle a
l'air de trousses agréable tant mieux et
puis si à un moment donné c'est la femme
qui nous ouvre la porte ou qui nous aide
à mettre maintenant tous qui nous a aidé
à marcher droit qu'on a trop bu bien on
veut j'espère qu'on va être content
aussi
mais sans la paix le ca de l'entr'aide
et
ce qui manque en fait est très mou du
getty et
par rapport aux mouvements sociaux donc
ça c'est une perspective peut-être plus
militants que qui consomme pas la
majorité des personnes mais
mais dans les mouvements sociaux et on a
aussi beaucoup en amérique du nord sur
des rapports houleux de deux autochtones
les premières nations où le theux afro
américaines par exemple et aux luttes
féministes en amérique du nord on a
beaucoup développé ça existe un peu ici
aussi ce genre de bronze ou de réflexion
des réflexions sujet de
la commission de ses plus dans un mode
de militants mais
leur le rôle le rôle et les fonctions
des études et dante de la part des
alliés donc dans le cas des premières
nations c'est les personnes qui sont des
descendants d'immigrants coloniale dans
le cas des afro américains chez les
personnes blanches par exemple et dans
le cas des femmes ce sera les personnes
les hommes et comment est-ce qu'on peut
être des bons alliés donc là il ya
différentes discussions là-dessus il ya
différents points de vue et les films ne
s'entendent pas et et on peut se faire
des choix je pense qu'il faut essayer
d'être en discussion avec d'autres
femmes et d'autres féministes je pense
aussi que nécessairement si on est un
homme profondément par exemple
nécessairement va indisposer certaines
féministes juillet certaines féministes
qui sont plus ou moins d'accord avec le
choix qu'on aurait fait qu'on ne fasse
rien ou qu'on fasse quelque chose dira
toujours une manière de voir ça comme
n'étant pas et dans ce qui est ce qui
est ce qui est normal parce qu'en fait
on est dans une situation paradoxale et
notre action ne peut pas toujours et
seulement aidantes mais un des critères
dont
2,2
un peu moralisateur peut-être mais un
des critères de du sérieux de notre
engagement si je veux dire par rapport à
cette question de de l'égalité de la
liberté de la dignité de la sécurité
pour les femmes c'est aussi de voir
quand tu disais tout à l'heure mais
c'est notre lutte ou 6 ou c'est notre
cause aussi c'est de voir à quel point
ce l'est réellement et donc à quel point
on est prêt à prendre des risques mais
aussi parce que c'est assez d'être axé
notre cause moussy mais en fait c'est la
leur et nous on peut toujours décider de
revenir dans des pâtures
macheath masculin
patriarcal c'est que c'est du terrain
c'est facile de retourner dans des
bonnes vieilles habitudes de
socialisation on pense que les femmes
doivent des choses et ne doivent la plus
d'attention plus d'écouté psychologique
des services divers domestique parental
voire même sexuelle et cetera est donc
amené on peut dire ouais bon mais moi je
veux essayer de changer les
comportements et d'avoir des
comportements plus égalitaire et plus
attentifs n'importe quel moment on peut
décider contre on arrête ça et on
revient dans nous dans nos bonnes
vieilles chaussures alors que les femmes
elle sied si elle arrête un moment donné
ben en fait elle continue à se faire à
se faire approprié ou se faire violenter
où se fout ouais dans des situations
d'indignité ou d'insécurité ou de
sentiment d'injustice et donc elles leur
lutte et elle implique des coûts des
effort
une sorte d'obligation sont pas obligés
de lutter ce n'est pas le bon terme mais
parce que c'est vraiment elle qui sont
concernés en premier essai et c'est pas
nous et donc là je reviens la question
des coûts et donc c'est ça revient un
peu à la question de tout à l'heure que
se posaient sur wii mais bon on n'arrive
pas à voir des femmes dans notre
émission mais justement c'est qu'elle
est fort vous êtes prêt à faire est-ce
que c'est simplement une bonne intention
qui vous êtes absa marche pas c'est pas
pour ça non mais attends je te réponds
oui
on a un planning déjà qu'on peut
ralentir donc on a commencé à y tient on
a essayé de faire trois shows de faire
plus de femmes android sujets complexes
ainsi suite sauf que on nous a proposé
lundi que des experts parce qu'on s'est
fait rentrer dedans par des féministes
et oui voilà que entre mâles blanchi
mais écoutez les nounous verts trop de
propositions il nous envoyait un
catalogue d'experts oui nos sujets
principe ou c'est terrorisme oui ça je
crois que vous avez des créneaux on a
des créneaux il s'est créé nous sont
occupé la majeure partie par des mâles
blancs d'obus dont mes yeux
ou des chaudrons déjà on fait des
efforts surhumains pour la rue des
jeunes du moins pas au dessus de 76 ans
qui veulent parler on avait proposé à la
porte parole du quai d'orsay de notre
ministère des affaires étrangères il
s'est dégonflé mais
ça avait été un homme comme celui commun
voilà qu'ils ont à proposer s'est
dégonflé pareil mais je vais vous donner
un bon exemple donc vous êtes fait grève
donc vous êtes un non c'est pas à vous
de faire grève vous êtes un
un nouveau créneau c'est le terrorisme
je viens dire ça ou la finance non
christine lagarde se serait restaurée
sur le terrorisme et donc la question
c'est comment vous définissez le
terrorisme parce que des féministes ont
défini par exemple la violence conjugale
comme du terrorisme et familiale et
d'outils pratiques et de religion oui
mais moi ce que je te dis c'est oui mais
justement il ya le créneau puis après ça
comment on définit large du créneau et
il ya des films et ce qu'ils disent oui
mais la définition du terrorisme si on
parle de terrorisme est logique du
terroriste elle le fait que une certaine
violence ou une menace de violence créé
un effet de tes erreurs dans une
population dans une catégorie ben il ya
des films et ce qu'ils disent en fait
les femmes sont soumises à un terroriste
le terrorisme de la violence conjugale
de la violence familiale ou si les états
terroristes comme celui dont j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure que haïti dix mille sable
est par exemple l'attend en deux
semaines et à l'école polytechnique où
les attentes ont maintenant des
libertaires involontaire en amérique du
nord qui sous prétexte qu'ils n'ont pas
la sexualité qui lui l'or serait due
apparemment du simple fait qu'ils sont
des hommes par des femmes et qu'ils
soient qu'ils se disent scandalisés par
sa belle fille justifie en fait des
attentats
auxquels il fournit à toronto et je
tairai ce nom là donc là vous avez des
sujets sur le terrorisme c'est juste pas
la notion d'utérus que vous vous avez en
tête mais ça rentre dans la définition
du terrorisme selon d'autres d'autres
points de vue donc là déjà juste la
corde donc là déjà on est dans une
perspective et je dis pas que ça c'est
un coup pour vous mais c'est sûr on peut
on prédire c'est du travail il faut
travailler sur soi même il faut très
bien sûr il faut faire de l'effort de
voir les choses autrement dit de pas de
porte et l'écoutent et pas juste
d'arrêter à la première étape qui a mais
sont pas dans le créneau donc oui mais
le créneau peut-être il et puis il ya
peut-être plus de stock dans le créneau
que tu penses et peut-être qu'au fil de
saba il va avoir plus d'intervenants
terroirs différents points de vue et
vous allez avoir une conception et les
les adeptes de tinqueux view vont être
mieux informés sur la notion de
terrorisme je donne je donne cet exemple
mais juste terminée sur une autre
exemple qui est liée à la violence et
qui est un exemple
peut être plus clair si je peux dire la
question des coûts
tandis que ses notes lui aussi par
rapport aux violences en général que
subissent les femmes les écrits de les
femmes
si on était galice ont été guéris sont
dit bon on est contre ça donc on est
dépendant du bonhomme on est des bonnes
personnes les personnes juste et on est
contre ça mais je pense que là où on
peut on peut voir on peut voir
on peut voir le sérieux notre engagement
c'est est ce qu'on est prêt par exemple
perdre des amis
dans une situation où une femme dans
notre entourage par exemple dit en fait
j'ai été agressée ou harcelés ou je ne
sais pas en fait a eu des comportements
totalement inadmissible envers moi et je
veux plus le voir est ce qu'on est prêt
nous à perdre cet ami ou sept amis ou ce
que bien entendu souhaites tu dis ça
mais on se connaît pas mais en tout cas
ce que je peux dire c'est que je pense
que c'est c'est plutôt rare il ya plein
il ya plein de il ya plein d'hommes qui
préfèrent tenir l'iran serrer les coudes
ne pas croire la femme ou en tout cas
minimiser ce qu'elle dit et là je parle
de situation dans la vie privée mais
dans l'association dans l'es10 public ça
devient même farfelues ont secoué il ya
tout il ya toutes ces affaires là où en
fait il ya des hommes qui sont qu'ils
sont montés aux barricades un
appartement spectaculaire en france
c'est bernard henri lévy qui a
évidemment entendu parler et se prétend
comme défenseur des droits de l'homme et
là dans ce cas le terme est bien choisi
parce qu'en fait
lui ces bizarreries les défenseurs des
des peuples soumis à la tyrannie que ce
soit en tunisie ou en libye ou ou où les
où les kurdes mais quand ce sont des
femmes qui sont soumis à la tyrannie des
hommes c'est bizarre il prend la défense
des hommes dont il a pris la défense de
polanski il a pris la défense de son ami
dsk dominique strauss kahn et lui les
milliards d'avoirs de problème avec ça
en fait le problème c'est le premier
c'est les femmes c'est pas s'est passé
pas c'est pas ses amis de de la haute
deûle à de la haute société et donc lui
sans lien qui prend pas beaucoup de qui
prend pas beaucoup de risques ou qui
payent pas beaucoup de ces personnes
pour pour défendre la cause des femmes
qui apparemment intéresse pas vraiment
d'ailleurs donc ça c'est ça c'est ça
c'est des cds exemple on évalue est ce
que est ce que tu étais prêt à voir des
coûts et après ça évidemment ya tous les
trucs de base de des tâches domestiques
ou et moi je dis ça un jeu il ya plein
de moments qui tâches domestiques
mais le un partage plus égalitaire où
une prise de responsabilité des tâches
de métier qu'on vit en couple par
exemple et aux possesseurs 20e siècle
je la mets de l'évier moi je fais moins
moi j'ai des beaux discours mais il faut
parler à ma conjointe et considère pas
que je fais 50 % et la maison a fait
plus de tâches de mais c'est que moi et
plus de travail plus j'accumule du
retard dans mon travail salarié et
caetera et plus je retombe dans les
espèces de patin ou en fait après une ou
deux semaines je me trouve plein et que
je vous appelle ce soit je suis vraiment
dans le rush de chantal hochet terrain
ma conjointe de veuves de prendre en
charge plus leur fait c'est un jour 2
jours 3 jours quel jour on est ronde de
trois semaines piémont m10 là parce que
vous êtes même profil mais ce n'est pas
certain que view pour expliquer les
bienfaits du féminisme et du profane il
espère en fait moi je suis en train de
et donc à créer un rapport de force et
et seule manière de s'en sortir le
rapport de force moi je moi je suis prof
de sciences po et j'ai une expérience
militante et moi je crois que c'est un
rapport de force sans rapports de force
et les inégalités les injustices ne se
règle pas d'elle-même ya pas
les gens qui sont en poussant de deux
mines de domination ne se réveille pas
un matin en disant
mais purée on a fait une erreur on a des
esclaves quelle idée stupide on s'excuse
on ouvre la cage renom vous on vous ont
d'ailleurs on va on voit même vous
proposer des réparations
historique et économique et financière
parce que vraiment on n'avait pas
compris mais en fait l'esclavagé c'est
vraiment une idée ridicule et stupide et
scandaleuse et on est désolé ce stage ça
je mets le ca jamais fonctionné comme ça
et donc les patrons c'est la même chose
si a pas de syndicat s'est pas de
pression c'est duquel les patrons ils
vont faire tout ce qu'ils peuvent pour
maximiser leurs profits ont passé le
même horaire ouais en fait je viens de
lire marx est en fait ouais
le capital c'est pas terrible sûrement d
aller en fait ce que je vous propose
qu'à partir de maintenant je ne sois
plus votre patron on soit tous des
emplois comme tout le monde et on
fonctionne au start et enseignants
fonctionnaires ouimet est en
fonctionnement oui mais c'est pas parce
qu'ils ont lu marx et en fonctionner en
fonctionne en autogestion ça va ça
fonctionne pas comme ça et donc dans les
rapports entre les hommes et les femmes
dans des sociétés comme les autres au
niveau de la socialisation au niveau de
la discrimination au niveau des boys
club à lire un livre de martine delvaux
qui vient de sortir au québec mais qui
doit arriver problement bientôt les boys
club donc le boys club un livre un livre
aux éditions du remue ménage encore
martine delvaux donc les canalise donc
cette logique cette logique des boys
club et cette prégnance de cet esprit
boys club et c'était l'affluence des
boys web dans les sociétés donc on met
tout ça ensemble la socialisation le
sentiment que des choses nous sont dus
simplement parce qu'on est des hommes
c'est un sentiment de de castres
oui il faut dire il faut du rapport de
force il faut il faut il faut qu'il faut
que les féministes
quelle que soit leur tendance soit en
tout temps dans le rapport de force
collectif et individuel et je reviens
cette idée de l'imbrication avec la vie
privée dans le cadre des rapports entre
les hommes et les femmes et dans la vie
privée et
et
donc est donc voila
tout temps tout en faisant tout en
faisant la sueur taz que qu'elle doit
faire et qu'elles font ces femmes et
donc et donc ça commence à être
beaucoup
être beaucoup de l'aide beaucoup de
trash beaucoup de responsabilités
beaucoup de beaucoup d'efforts beaucoup
de fatigue est pour le moment beaucoup
de frustration et donc je reviens à la
question qui me disait au tout début par
rapport aux féministes radicales où elle
arrête quelques cumulus considérant tout
ça je trouve que moins les filets sont
très modérés
et quelques geeks a même dit moi je
connais des films laisserait du
calendrier le terme puis liste radicale
titeuf qui est un cliché - qui est
quelque chose de péjoratif mais moi à
montréal je suis si on peut dire entouré
de féministes radicales dans mon milieu
milieu amical on m'aide à ma vie privée
au travail et caetera et il les clichés
sur les féministes radicales sont
qu'elles détruisent la famille qu'elle
aime pas les hommes et ces terrains
sont absurdes en fait je vois des je
vois défiler ce qui se considéraient se
qualifieraient dicale
être tout de suite
en charge mentale est en prise de
responsabilité par exemple quand leur
père devient malade parce qu'il est trop
vieux
de s'occuper d'aider des personnes du
personnage est ce qu'on appelle au
québec les aidants naturels
c'est pas parce que les féministes
radicales sont finies serait décalé
qu'ils ont une analyse extrêmement
critique de ces rapports sociaux qui en
fait au final ne se sentent pas quand
même responsable
et qu'elles ne font pas ce travail qui
est lentement
leurs frères ou des hommes des hommes
qui se disent révolutionnaire d'extrême
gauche et chez des rats ne font pas il
ya un commentaire sur un autre chat qui
dit je me souviens de l'interview
d'isabelle saporta fait par singer view
dans laquelle elle exprime et qu'elle
voulait retrouver un homme avec un grand
h un bûcheron de mémoire
avec des couilles
est ce que est ce que ça c'est pour le
québec ça au nom du show dans le sang
sur lui côté village alizés karoui qui
va bien sûr
est-ce qu'il ya pas aussi chez les
femmes des femmes au fait qu'ils
maintiennent ce système là d'oppression
des femmes oui vous fait pour les
sensibiliser elle
c'est pas toi et moi de les sensibiliser
et bon et les femmes vont travailler
entre elles à se sensibiliser et 7e
convainquent ou partager des expériences
partagées des années mais ça c'est pas
c'est pas
c'est c'est juste jeune groupe je ne
suis pas sûr de saisir le sens du
commentaire des femmes qui n'annonçait
ça j'ai compris qu'est ce qui est décrit
comme situation mais est ce que le sens
qui est des femmes en fête qui veulent
simplement le stéréotype du bal du bidon
qui l'aura décrit depuis des années et
qu'elles sont elles sont dans ce type là
où tant que les mecs machiste absolument
bien sûr mais ça c'est pas c'est qu'en
dis tu t'es dit non mais ça y est
y'a pas de problème c'est juste j'essaie
de comprendre le
sens qu est-ce qu est-ce que qu'est-ce
que ce commentaire voulait dire de
vision politique est-ce que c'était pour
elle est validée ou valider quelque
chose où c'était simplement
mettre mettre en lumière ce type de ce
type de situation et et par rapport à ça
donc évidemment qu'il ya ça
comme il ya comme il ya des femmes qui
sont comme les femmes et des féministes
qui veulent des hommes moins viril comme
il ya des films qui sont lesbiennes
bisexuels comme il ya encore une fois il
ya tous les modèles disponibles et on
peut choisir l'exemple qu'on veut pour
prouver ce qu'on veut mais il faut
regarder il faut garder les tendances
mais de ce sont ces passionnés pour
tempérer cette question c'est dans
toutes les luttes politiques dans toutes
les situations de le système
inégalitaire il ya des gens qui si on
peut dire qu'ils se retrouvent pas du
côté qu'on pense qu'il devrait être en
terme de camp politique et donc en
israël par exemple il y a des palestine
et des palestiniens qui collaborent avec
les autorités palestiniennes ayez et
avec les autorités israéliennes par père
dont il ya quelques jouets fait juif qui
sont en fait du côté pro palestiniens à
l'époque de l'apartheid il y avait des
blancs afrikaners qui était du côté de
nelson mandela pas beaucoup mais y en
avait quelques uns qui étaient contre
l'apartheid et il y avait évidemment des
noirs en afrique du sud qui étaient en
fait des collabos c'est ce qu'on appelle
le principe du collaborateur et donc ça
il ya ce à gaza tout le temps il ya des
salariés il ya des salariés qui sont
contre les syndicats et qui pensent que
le patron est un bon patron et qui en
fait espèrent eux mêmes devenir
millionnaire mais qui pense pas fait que
les que les calices et la review que
leurs collègues devraient lutter
ensemble et puis il ya quelques patrons
qui des fois on une bonne pensée pour
leurs employés qui ceux qui votent même
parti socialiste ça existe encore en
france ne s'est pas trop là je suis un
peu perdu et tout ça mais soyez plus
socialisme est bon ce sont nos problèmes
et donc dans toutes les luttes
politiques il ya des piliers des
personnes qui sont pas dans le camp
compense où elle devrait être pour
différentes raisons et c'est des choix
c'est des parcours de vie c'est des
histoires de contacter cette histoire de
menaces des histoires de calcul de coûts
et bénéfices des histoires de
socialisation cdd il ya plein de raisons
qui expliquent qu'on soit dans un camp
dans un conte dans l'autre et donc bien
sûr qu évidemment aujourd'hui il ya des
femmes et même des féministes qui qui
tombe amoureuse d'un homme d'hommes
d'hommes virils et qui arrive il ya même
des féministes qui sont dans des
relations des relations hétérosexuelles
violente c'est tout à fait cette
question de ces situations
malheureusement acharif cette position
alors dit pourquoi la convergence des
luttes sociales et des luttes féministes
est elle si difficile
je ne sais pas quoi on fait référence
exactement à ce que c'est si difficile
je ne sais pas
voulait bien vos questions non mais
c'est juste que
c'est des questions écrites on n'est pas
devant la personne non quand on peut pas
demander de de préciser ce qui est en
jeu ce que je sais c'est que en fait il
ya des 10 par rapport au film essaie d
intégration des imbrications au niveau
des luttes par exemple dans les
syndicats en france je pense que c'est
comme au québec et ailleurs il ya des
commissions femmes par exemple des
commissions c'est que c'est sous des
commissions ceci ce lob pour les femmes
donnant 10 dans des syndicats donc ça
c'est une imbrication de lutte il ya des
il ya des femmes féministes qui sont
dans le syndicalisme des femmes
féministes sont dans le mouvement
écologiste il ya des camps il y avait
une nuit debout par exemple il y avait
des commissions enfin moody comme
commission de ces soins psychiatriques
ne sait pas trop comment ça s'appelait
dans les dents dans ces luttes donc
c'est c'est un briquet il ya des
manifestations du 1er mai il ya des
femmes et des féministes par ailleurs
donc je sais pas si c'est
si c'est si difficile ou plus difficile
que l'imbrication que la convergence
avec d'autres luttes les limites
peut-être seul et même la convergence et
peut-être même plus forte et
l'implication est peut-être plus forte
après ça c'est sûr que ça c'est
l'histoire dé l'histoire du mouvement
féministe et 2c de se retrouver dans des
mouvements sociaux progressistes ou à
prétention révolutionnaire est de
constater en fait que ces mouvements
sont
dominé en fait par des hommes machiste
qui traite les femmes comme des les
camarades de femmes comme des
comme des serviteurs comme des com dcom
des servantes comme des objets sexuels
et ça on a des excédents des exemples
récurrent dans l'histoire l'histoire des
dernières générations et ce qu'on
appelle de féministes radicales des
années 60 début 70
la plupart de ces féministes en france
aux états unis compris dans les
mouvements pro américain avant d'être
féministe elles sont des femmes
d'extrême gauche anti impérialiste
contre la guerre du vietnam de mai 68
dans des groupes maoïstes dans des
groupes anarchistes du terrain elles
viennent de là ces féministes radicales
et pourquoi elles deviennent féministe
c'est parce que dans leur dans leur
mouvement social elle réalise en fait
que les mecs sont des sons sont
monstrueux et que c'est un bon club et
qu'ils se tiennent entre eux et qui est
des agressions sexuelles et qui a de la
domination masculine dans leur
organisation et c'est comme ça qu'elle
devienne qu'il devienne qui devient de
fait n'est pas seulement féminisme et
qu'elle devienne féministes radicales
c'est vrai chez les afro-américains
beaucoup de féministes afro américaine
c'est vrai chez les finances françaises
c'est vrai au québec chez les féministes
radicales il définit liste d'extrême
droite
dans fait une utilisation de funès perd
l'extrême droite de rassemblement
national si je me trompe pas j'espère
que je dis pas de bêtises qui lance un
front national qui a changé de nom pour
de son bizarre
tous deux joué oui
mais ça reste la famille le pen quand
même
mais oui le front national seraient
centre national s'il ne trompe pas mais
j'espère je dis pas de bêtises je suis
la politique française mais j'ai pas
tout et que je peux faire des justes pas
que je ne fais pas d'erreur mais ma
compréhension c'est par rapport à
par rapport au racisme contre l'islam
est contre contre les populations
musulmanes et il me semble que le
rassemblement national par exemple
jouent la carte de nous on défend les
femmes on défend les homosexuels on est
en france on est des gens civilisés pas
comme ces barbares qui menace qui
menacent donc une sorte de récupération
de récupération d'une sorte de féminisme
effectivement tout ce qui peut qui peut
et qui peut être qui peut être qui peut
être du côté de l'extrême droite ou
d'alger j'en profite pour poser la
question de chillou
pourquoi les féministes soutiennent
l'islam et au contraire se lance dans la
guerre contre l'église catholique
que pense-t-il de la phrase islam is
right à buttes ou ben tu veux avec
l'accent américain
pourquoi les féministes soutiennent
l'islam et au contraire se lance dans la
guerre contre l'église catholique que
pense-t-il de la phrase islam is right à
bochum
c'est une phrase que j'ai pas vraiment
vu donc je sais pas d'où elle vient je
ne sais pas aussi de quelle faiblesse il
parlait à quoi il ferait la personne
fait référence
jeu
je réponds mais c'est peut-être
complètement à côté de ce que du sujet
donc je réponde rapidement pour pomme
est ce que les gars aient trop longtemps
m quand des féministes on peut soutenir
l'islam
il ya une liste on peut soutenir les
deux religions
oui c'est de formule 1 qu'il ya des
idées féministes musulmanes il est né ce
chrétien et les faits mais ce juive ya
des fumiers ce protestante
moi je moi comme jésus alors je suis je
suis athée en plus je suis pas féministe
je suis un homme éprouvé maison que j'ai
pas trop d'avis là dessus c'est parce
que mes l'ixo femis vont pas tellement
de ce côté là mais j'ai lu un peu sur le
féminisme musulman sur le fait mais ce
chrétien catholique du début du xxème
siècle entre autres c'est assez simple
il ya des collègues encore aujourd'hui
qui sont dans les perspectives comme ça
en sciences des religions et elle est là
qu elle
elle critique en fait de l'intérieur
elles ont la foi donc bon je suis athée
mais elles auraient elles ont la foi
elle croit en dieu elle se considère
christian nook et neko musulmanes ou
juives mais dans la lecture ou dans
l'interprétation qu'elle fonde de leurs
saintes écritures et de de la foi et de
la compréhension qu'elles ont de dieu
c'est ma compréhension de leurs
positions et le disent en fait c'est
compatible avec une égalité entre les
sexes soit un respect d un respect plus
grand des dix femmes et elles se
retrouvent à critiquer de l'intérieur en
fait des interprétations vraiment
sexistes et misogyne et patriarcale des
des textes sacrés ou de la volonté de
dieu ou de tel de tels sourate ou tel
passage de la bible ou de tels
commentaires du pape est donc dans ce
sens là elles sont ce sont des faits me
laisse musulmane ou chrétienne ou juive
bon mais après ça je sais pas plus
pessimiste que ça de deux sommets et par
rapport à l'islam j'imagine que la
question fait référence
au débat sont ce qu'on appelle deux des
basses eaux le débat sur le foulard en
france je me donne ça doit faire
référence à cette question là où il ya
des faiblesses qui sont faits
solidaires en fait
des femmes musulmanes qui portent le
foulard ou qui critiquent l'islamophobie
j'imagine que c'est ça fait référence à
cet enjeu qui est qui qui est toxique
totalement le champ politique français
depuis cinquante ans ouaf depuis même
150 ans depuis début de la colonisation
des opérations coloniale en egypte et en
algérie mais
mais mais
à yar est tellement de choses à dire là
dessus c'est tellement décourageant moi
je suis arrivé en france le 13 octobre
et là il ya quelques semaines et comme
je faisais de l'insomnie à cause du
décalage horaire avec elle je me
retrouve dans les hôtels dans ceux de la
france parce que j'étais invité dans des
librairies ou dans des universités pour
faire des présentations
je vous ai des insomnies donc à 2 3
heures du matin pour moi y était 8
heures le soir donc je dormais pas et
donc je vais axer la télé donc j'ai
zappé joyet si news et bfm tv ça ou des
trucs comme ça et là vous vous rappelez
mi-octobre y avait une mère
accompagnatrices qui porte un foulard
qui apparemment
déstabiliser la france
puissance du g7 65 millions de français
puissances nucléaires puis une des
principales puissances économiques et
utérin et là il ya une mères
accompagnatrices qui porte un foulard et
la libération compte et je pense et 85
débat de 180 intervenants un truc de
c'est complètement ridicule votre truc
là il faut
calmer la crise rend plus intéressant et
et femmes en arabie saoudite et
bricoleurs qui se fait fouetter
c'est ridicule c'est absurde qui et qui
pour cela est donc dans le contexte
français le contexte québécois en ce
moment est en train de prendre dérive
depuis quelques années deux du même type
il ya effectivement des filets ce que
qu'on connaît que je connais qu'on
côtoie ecce terra qui disent danser dans
cette situation là l'enjeu n'est pas
est-ce que je suis pour l'islam ou pas
pour l'islam c'est pas ça l'enjeu
l'enjeu est dans une histoire occident
occidental en fait qu'il devrait
être connu et être
valorisée c'est le principe du
de la tolérance envers les minorités
religieuses c'est c'est un principe
extrêmement important leurs détracteurs
disent voilà les musulmans quand ils
sont en minorité elite pour les
minorités mais quand ils sont en
majorité ils écrasent les minorités
qu'est ce qu'on peut leur répondre à ces
gens là on répond ce que je viens de
dire c'est le principe occidentale de
tolérance envers les minorités
religieuses que si on oublie ce principe
de tolérance envers les minorités
religieuses ce qu'on a c'est au mieux de
la discrimination et au pire d'autres
choses des génocides c'est l'histoire
occidentale ce site à lui les guerres du
16e siècle jusqu'au xxème siècle
l'absence de tolérance pour les
minorités religieuses c'est ça que ça a
donné je sais pas conservateur un
génocide mais je dis c'est ça l'histoire
bien civile c'est sa liste je ne parle
pas de guerre civile je dit juste c'est
ça l'histoire et c'est ça l'histoire de
l'occident le l'idée de la tolérance je
dis même pas de l'acceptation de la
tolérance tolérance le truc le plus miné
cette offre de vins voisin qui fait un
truc vous tolérez ce qui fait que vous
vous êtes pas nécessairement d'accord
avec lui vous n'allez pas faire ce que
lui fait vous voulez pas nécessairement
que ces vos enfants font ce qu'il faut
font face qui fait c'est le principe de
tolérance c'est presque c'est presque
méprisant des fois le temps presse de
tolérance je tolère toi
mais c'est un principe fondamental de
l'histoire occidentale qui est en train
d'être complètement oublié au nom de la
fameuse laïcité qui est un concept qui a
été totalement dévoyé et dans cette
lutte totalement toxiques il ya des
féministes qui sont qui se disent du
côté de la laïcité et qui disent que
l'islam opprime les femmes et que le
voile est un signe de pressions et donc
il faut en fait
dévoiler les femmes musulmanes ou en
tout cas les empêcher de se promener
vous allez dans l'espace public donc il
retourne chez elle en a presque fait
mais c'est un peu bizarre mais en tout
cas c'est le point de vue de ces
fumistes il ya plein d'autres féministes
qui disent maintenant le principe c'est
le principe de non discrimination et le
principe de tolérance et nous on se met
du côté des femmes musulmanes parce
qu'en fait c'est ça la ont dit les
signes religieux mais c'est pas la kippa
ou c'est pas le turban du que c'est la
femme musulmane c'est l'obsession
occidentale en ce moment et il ya des
féministes qui se met de son côté à la
fois dans une perspective ans intéressés
c'est dans une perspective féministe
et ça me semble et moi je suis plutôt de
ceux de ceux de ce camp quand je vois
tout le déferlement de boue au sujet de
des femmes qui portent le foulard alors
qu'elle est alors que l on rien d'autre
à ces femmes là ils ont pas et sont pas
propriétaires de banque et sont pas chef
de l'armée elles sont pas dans des
ministères et sont pas propriétaires des
cols et son copropriétaire de pitot
elles sont pas propriétaires de grandes
forcené sont pas propriétaires de médias
se sont en fait un peu les dernières des
dernières des femmes des femmes
musulmanes qui portent le foulard et
sont pas et sont pensés en situation de
domination et pourtant elles sont
traînés dans la boue mais tout le temps
depuis des années et les partis
politiques font leur campagne électorale
sur leur dos ou ils fonctionnent tous
des diversions la plupart du temps c'est
donc un problème ceci dit si on pense
que d'ici six ans et si on pense
qu'elles sont vraiment opprimés parce
qu'il ya des études qui disent qu'en
fait ces femmes et il ya une diversité
de raisons pour lequel elle commence à
porter le voile ou elle l'enlève où elle
le remet tout à quel âge ou tel âge
rapport à leur famille tu trahis plein
plein profil différent
si elles pensent qu'elles sont vraiment
imprimé par leur mari ou par leurs pairs
c'est pas elle qu'il faut fustiger c'est
complètement absurde c'est comme c'est
une femme pour lutter contre la violence
contre les femmes on voyait une femme
qui avait un oeil au beurre noir parce
qu'elle avait reçue une coup de poing de
son mari et en interdisant en fait aux
femmes de se connecter ou benoît dans
l'espace public en leur disant vous
retournez chez vous jusqu'à ce que vous
n'ayez plus de juger' noah je pense que
la logique de lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes apparaît très
rapidement totalement illogique est
totalement irrationnel donc si on pense
vraiment que les femmes musulmanes qui
portent un foulard sont opprimés
ben c'est pas c'est pas elle qu'il faut
discriminés
j'arrive on arrive à la fin d'autres
interview ça fait déjà environ deux
heures les allées russe quand
est-ce que tu as trois bouquins à
conseiller est-ce que des avants avant
de conseiller trois bouquins est ce que
tu veux qu'on rajoute quelque chose tu
veux qu'on discute de quelque chose en
particulier
non mais je pense qu'on en a déjà
beaucoup beaucoup parlé merci d'ailleurs
pour tout cet espace est un désavantage
de tinqueux view ce qu'on a on a
beaucoup d'espacé rack on a des
tribunaux vendrait autant de autant
l'espace un coup ci suivi parce que
bonjour à tous nous auditeurs fallou
heures pour castrés et ap ap et
d'eau mais
[Musique]
si ça vous dérange pas je pense que j'ai
envie de renommer les livres que j'ai
nommé juste pour que ça soit sur le vote
c'est a commencé que pour nom mais ça
c'est le sait c'est mon livre mais ça
c'est pas très important par rapport à
la question d'aujourd'hui il ya donc le
livre de mélissa blais jaillit les
féministes qui est donc sont vraiment
sur une étude de cette histoire
épouvantable de la tante féministe à
l'école polytechnique en 89 et de ses
suites et avec 1000 sablé et christine
bard une historienne
dans logic et spécialiste de
l'antisémitisme on est con a codirigé
ensemble un ouvrage qui s'appelle
antiféminisme et masculinisme c'est au
pluriel entre humanisme et masculinisme
dit aujourd'hui ça c'était s'est sorti
l'année dernière ça sur un ouvrage
collectif donc l' avantage dans un
ouvrage collectif évidemment c'est que
vous avez une diversité de sujets de
thématiques qui sont abordés et donc il
y à une retranscription d'une table
ronde sur trois femmes qui ont la foi
trois femmes religieuses une musulmanes
et une juive et une une chrétienne en
fait quatre femmes et une protestante et
catholique qui parle en fait de lens ou
nice dans l'ordre dans leurs religions
respectives dans leurs actions
religieuse et elle parle de comment ils
luttent sur ces enjeux donc ça c'est
déjà deux livres j'ai parlé aussi de
boys club de martine delvaux qui étaient
intervenus assez souvent dans les médias
français quand il y avait eu la fameuse
affaire de la ligue du lol vous rappelez
de la ligue du lol donc merci ne vous
vient de sortir un livre sur un essai
sur eux sur cette logique des boys club
du bruit ce club c'est quand on est dans
des environnements de non mixité mais
entre mecs et et on remarquera
d'ailleurs que souvent les mobilités
quand c'est celle des femmes ça crie au
scandale mais il ya plein d'endroits où
en fait les hommes on se retrouve entre
nous et apparemment ça c'est pas si
c'est pas un problème leurs sous marins
entre autres et dans les équipes de foot
et tout se vend
dans certains conseils d'administration
ou dans les airs religieux entre haute
et j'étais là j'avais mentionné aussi le
livre de 2
susan fallou dis donc backlash qui était
aussi sur une étude delà des discours de
crise de masculinité des discours
antisioniste dans les années 80 dans les
années reagan donc c'est ça nous met
dans une dans une logique que d'analyser
des constructions du
la pensée néoconservatrice
et puis et puis j'ai envie de le dire il
ya aussi d'aider des études
intéressantes mais malheureusement je
pense que c'est c'est seulement en
anglais non c'est pas vrai il ya des
livres qui sont en face et aussi par
exemple
belle boxe donc h ou au
ksv llb loucks une féministe
afro-américaine qui écrit un livre très
important qui s'appelle et pourtant ne
suis pas une femme si je me trompe pas
là du livre c'est dans la tradition
française et pourtant ne suis pas une
femme dans laquelle elle explique
l'histoire des femmes afro américaine de
l' esclavage a aujourd'hui mais aussi de
leur lutte et là dedans fait qui est
intéressant par rapport aux sujets
d'aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya tout un
passage sur les années 60 70 où elle
montre que le discours de la crise de la
masculinité il va être utilisée par la
maison blanche pour essayer de trouver
une excuse ou une explication aux
problèmes de la communauté afro
américaine de l'époque donc les jeunes
plus autour de délinquance de criminels
de criminalité de de
trafic de drogue et une période
d'emprisonnement et et la maison blanche
où douze années 60 déposé
rend public un rapport sur la famille
noire commandé à l'époque ce terme
péjoratif mais celui j'utilise et
kids a en fait on comprend en fait c'est
vrai qu'un peu de rester ce mot aux
etats unis quand même il faut l'avouer
odieuse les 60 mais en fait le vrai
problème dans la communauté afro
américaine c'est que la communauté
afro-américaine et un matriarcat
l'homme afro américain est en crise
d'identité masculine le père est exclu
de la famille les la famille est géré
par des mères monoparentales et c'est
pour ça qu'en fait les jeunes garçons
qui n'ont pas de modèle de figure
paternelle de discipline et les
autorités font n'importe quoi et et tout
fout le camp et donc la conclusion
d'ailleurs du rapport aux besoins 60 et
offre est intéressante et des pour
retrouver une figure d'autorité
disciplinaire parental on encourage en
fait les jeunes afro américain à
entrer dans l'armée est bon comme par
hasard c'était début de la guerre du
vietnam mais
dû rentrer pour ce faire pousser des
couilles c'est ça oui pour avoir pour
pour apprendre la discipline et avoir
une figure d'autorité et revenir avec
une discipline personnelle si on revient
évidemment et la pouvoir fonder une
famille comme un bon père de famille
américain qui sait ce qu'a dit cela en
vue sur le coup d'oeil je veux pas le
savoir et
[Musique]
donc ça c'était un rapport le rapport
money delà de la maison blanche qui
avait été évidemment totalement décrit
par la communauté afro américaine en
disant ça c'est un discours raciste
évidemment
stéréotypé et une hauteur comme patrice
et ils connaissent donc nos clients
intéressants à lire c'est la pensée
féministe noir la pensée fumée soin de
mettre c'est le colza tout un passage où
il dit en fait le problème le problème
de la communauté américaine africaine
c'est certainement pas les mères
monoparentales en fait heureusement que
nous avons le maire ponot monoparentales
il faudra en fait ériger des monuments à
la gloire des mères monoparentales
car ce sont en fait des héroïnes qui à
force de sueur d'efforts de nuit blanche
du tout seul ou entre elles elles
s'entraident ou s'ils font métier mais
la communauté en vie même au niveau des
mouvements sociaux et sont effectivement
et joue un rôle de très important et
donc bello qui rappelle par ailleurs que
une fois qu'on a dit ça au début des
années 60 par rapport à la communauté
africaine avec la commune offre et
canadaeast ça c'est du racisme velozzi
le problème c'est que dans les années
qui vont suivre il va y avoir le
mouvement du black paru le mouvement
front américain dirigé par des hommes
charismatiques délit de malcom x étant
évidemment le pousser les mégane
plusieurs autres et en fait les femmes
afro américaine qui sont dans ce
mouvement de revendication de droits
civiques et plus radicale du black paru
du black panthers et tout ça vont
rapidement réalisé en fait qu'ils sont
face à des machos et que dans la
mobilisation pour les droits civiques ou
pour la
l'émancipation des afro américains les
afro-américains ce phénomène
classique dans les situations coloniales
et dans la situation racistes se sont
retrouvés à être à subir des
dénigrements de leur virilité
par l'idéologie suprématiste blanche ont
dénigré on ridiculise la sexualité de
l'homme noir et l'homme noir militants
du black power dis moi m'ont même on m'a
cause c'est à la fois la lutte pour
oppose pour une lutte nationaliste afro
américaine mais aussi la lutte pour
devenir un vrai homme face à l'homme
blanc et
dans cette lutte ils vont dire le
problème c'est que dans notre communauté
afro-américaine nous sommes
effectivement castrés par les mères
monoparentales
nous les fameux premier kane nos soeurs
ont trop d'influx ans en plus ils
commencent à en avoir qui ceux qui se
disent féministe et nous critiques
disent qu'on est des matchs et cgt y
donc et ce sont des des ennemis des
traîtres des traîtresses et donc est
donc d afro féministe effectivement en
fait on fait des militantes afro
américaines vont devenir féministes
radicales à cause de cette situation
comme je mentionnais tout à l'heure pour
les groupes d'extrême gauche
elles vont être face à des avec
camarades des frères qui se baissent
avec elle le racisme mais qui sont des
matches et ce qu'ils sont des dès qu'ils
sont c'est que c'est ce qu'ils peuvent
être même violent envers les femmes et
donc il va y avoir tout un débat dans la
communauté afro américaine que belux
entre autres explique très bien sur
cette question de la crise damas culte
et comment elle va être utilisée est
retournée est retourné en fait dans des
luttes à la fois interraciales prend
près des thermes américain et à
l'intérêt de la communauté
afro-américaine et comment les
acouphènes ils vont devoir lutter sur
deux fois sur le front rester sur le
front sexy dans leur propre communauté
je lance la c b look ce temps je t'ouvre
de parenté je les tire un commentaire on
a reçu sur le tchat sur les sujets sont
libres 2 nous sommes libres et j'ai
presque libre est un libraire nous écrit
ça n'a rien à voir c'est une question
que j'ai passé mes jeunes passent avec
la souris dessus j'aimerais que tu lui
réponds tu d'accord je vais je vais je
vais lire le commentaire est toujours
les pros d'accord
puisque les hommes sont monstrueux
virgules ne faut-il pas que ce monsieur
devienne un transsexuel pour
l'interrogation
comme ça au moins il pourrait être au
bout de sa logique c'est sous 2019 tout
ça en plus quel progrès ce mec est
incroyablement dangereux et en fait il
veut nous couper les couilles
c'est bien il faut encadrer ces
commentaires là c'est tous ces
commentaires là c'est démontre
exactement ce que j'ai donc en fait la
logique de la castration tout ça donc ça
encore réduire les identités à nos
organes génitaux c'est ce et
j'espère que cette personne va bien
j'espère que la libye elle est bien dans
sa peau et cali patrouille pas trop
angoissé par tout ça parce que parce que
ce m en fait je comprends même pas sur
le fondement de ce genre de commentaire
je ne dis pas que les
on m'a déjà même on a déjà porté plainte
à moi et à d'autres à d'autres collègues
féministe à la commission des droits de
la personne au québec pour pour discours
haineux envers les hommes
bon donc moi je tient des discours
haineux envers les hommes je suis mise
en eau si je j'ai une haine de moi-même
quand tu dis misandre ce qui est
l'inversé misandrie hockey et je serai à
beat agent du million de poulets oui je
serai habité d'une n 2 n 2 mois et est
tout seul
tu sais pourquoi je te jeter sous 10 est
ce que mon terrain parce qu'on va
recevoir énormément de commenté win à
saint-cricq la tête non mais ça me je
trouve ça comme je dis moi je j'accumule
le dandé dans des archives les à ce jour
ce sont tous les livres que je publie
quand je dis tous les jours ce tout en
les insultes donc
vous fait prévu pour le vainqueur
apparemment publier des livres c'est un
effet
mais
mais c'est donc sur cette question de la
crise de la masculinité de propos
proféministes et où il ya tout à cette
remise en question donc de mon identité
sexuelle ou et
et
est en fait je dis pas qu'elle est je
dis pas que les hommes sont monstrueux
c'est pas vrai je sais c'est que c'est
c'est eh c'est pas une question de d'un
des hommes ou d'amour des femmes sa note
d'un point de vue politique tout ça n'a
pas de sens c'est je dis juste que nous
sommes dans des sociétés où il y à des
inégalités des rapports de domination
des rapports inégalitaires des rapports
de force qui a des catégories sociales
ou de sexe dans ce que l'avion qui en
plus davantage - davantage il y en a qui
tu es mais qui se font tuer il y en a
qui ont peur y en a qui ont peur il y en
a qui font parie en actions ta peur et
tu t il y en a qui font du travail
gratuit pour les autres et il y en a qui
font pas de rêver gratuit il y en a qui
s'attendent à ce qu'on leur fait on
travaille gratuitement pour eux qu'on
leur rend des services sexuels et c'est
de ça que je parle et c'est des
processus de socialisation c'est des
processus institutionnalisée cd
processus de relations interpersonnelles
et de relations collectives et c'est pas
ça n'a rien à voir avec les jeunes ou
avec la préhistoire ou avec les
chromosomes ou avec eux ou avec les
configurations de nos organes génitaux
qu'on a des testicules pas des
testicules et des ovaires pâte de verre
un utérus pas d'utérus sa part rapport
avec ça c'est des marqueurs c'est pas de
la cause de rien du tout et
et
et donc c'est une question de c'est une
question politique et donc sa gelée
peut-être pas mentionné mais pour moi
moi j'ai pas psychologue et
sexologue je suis militant
à mes heures quand j'ai le temps et en
sciences politiques et donc pour moi
l'identité masculine il nantes ces
féminines j'aurais peut-être dû
commencer par ça
c'est ce sont des identités politiques
pourquoi je dis que ce sont des
identités politiques parce qu en fait
être un homme
implique tendanciellement je dis
toujours c'est tendancielle c'est de
manière générale à voir certains
privilèges avoir certains le pc d'avoir
d exercer des rapports de domination
d'avoir des attentes et d'obtenir même
qu'on demande rien d'ailleurs des
services de la part de femmes que ce
soit notre mère notre conjointe notre
soeur une amie ecce terra on va on va
nous servir et est allé à l'inversé
identité féminine du tout si une danse
et politique parce que elle et
elle est en interaction avec l'identité
masculine ont des rapports inégalitaires
et dons directs un rapport hiérarchique
et des rapports inégalitaires y compris
au niveau au niveau du travail qui fait
le travail qui veulent trouver
gratuitement des ressources du contrôle
des ressources de la propriété du
terrain donc ça c'est ça c'est politique
c'est pas c'est psychologique c'est pas
effectif c'est pas chromosome x et pas
hormonal cdc des rapports sont des
rapports politiques et il ya différents
noms pour parler de ce système la
monstruosité dont parle monsieur ou
madame je sais pas c'est qui qui crient
ou ce peut être une personne trans dire
je sais pas mais j'en doute très
fortement mais
l'autonome c'est ce genre comme on dit
c'est à dire identifiés comme tels à la
naissance et dont son identité de genre
correspondants sont sexy dance la
naissance mais donc c'est dans ce pour
parler de ce système il ya différents
termes la notion de patria recueille les
notions de sexisme il ya la notion de
phallocratie qui l'a évoque justement la
question du pénis et des testicules et
tout ça qui semble intéresser messieurs
il y a
il ya l'émotion de macheist qui est sûre
d'attitude il ya un terme qui est peu
utilisé en france est plus utilisé en
anglais aussi mais qui vient en fait d
afro américaine et des féministes
américaines comme francis francis b 11
je sais pas comment prononce by ea est
elle qui tuent neuf aux féministes dans
les années soixante dix où un collectif
comme les radicaux lesbians aux
divisions des sources de unis où marlène
dixon qui était une féministe socialiste
aux états unis
ils ont eu la mention de supprimer 6 me
mall c'est un calque de la notion de
suprématisme blanc mais je dis pas que
les autres concepts sont pas
intéressants au patriarcat domination
masculine machisu ça mais ce que j'aime
avec la notion de suprématie sme
suprématie blanche commun si ce mal
c'est que ça évoque sa évoque une
posture de la pression du suprématisme
évoque une posture en fait de caste une
posture aristocratique une posture que
des choses nous sont dus en anglais on
dit and try to
try to c'est à dire s'il sait difficile
à traduire en thaï tô dans français mais
ça fait référence avec decitre quelque
chose mais dut en fonction donc c'est
très la notion du tetris et ses
interviews c'est le titre de noblesse
quelques je suis en tête haute je suis
quelque chose me dit en fonction de mon
site parce que je suis un duc ou parce
que je suis un blanc dans le
suprématisme blanc ou parce que je suis
un homme dans le suprématisme mal et
cette question de suprématie sme qui
nous est induite dans la socialisation
masculine que un homme doit s'attendre à
certaines choses des femmes les femmes
sont faites pour nous servir et j'étais
rats c'est vraiment une
posture d'aristocrates de castres et
qu'est-ce qu'il ya aussi qu'il y ait à
une notion de supprimer 6 mai une notion
reste aux critiques de supériorité et
aristocratique de castres c'est la
notion du scandale de crime de lèse
majesté c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas ce
qu'on pense qui nous est dû de par notre
titre de mal c'est un scandale c'est une
crise c'est une crise de la masculinité
c'est une crise des rapports de genre on
de déférence envers nous on ne nous rend
pas le service qui nous est dû et on
épand on n'est pas en crise ont fait des
crises et les crises peuvent être très
violente les aristocrates penser qu'ils
avaient des choses qu'il aurait été
tellement dur que en fait la plèbe
devait se décoiffer devant les
aristocrates et si la plèbe ce légume
chasser sur le teint la terre des
aristocrates on l'étendait pour un lapin
ou une cour aujourd'hui les célibataires
et volontaire aux deux nuits dans le
réseau d insein ils disent si je n'ai
pas la sexualité qui m'est dû en tant qu
homme hétérosexuel je suis prêt à
célébrer pas héroïsé un homme qui comme
un attentat au nom de cette cause le
tueur de l'école polytechnique dont j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure et sur lequel porte
le livre 2000 sablais lui il a été
héroïque et il ya des gens qui disent
c'est un héros et un martyr de la cause
des hommes et lui consorts il eut en
compterait qui en fait il n'avait pas eu
ce qui lui était dû en tant qu'homme
c'est à dire une place à polytechnique
par exemple c'était la rumeur qui
circulait qu'il avait été refusée à
polytechnique et est donc cet esprit
aristocratique cet esprit de caste et
d'esprit les super yachts et malki
calquée sur la notion de supériorité
blanche elle elle vit avec un dernier
élément qui est très important dans la
notion de suprématisme qu'on retrouve
dans l'esprit massis mme blanc et qu'on
retrouve dans le stream à 6me mal c'est
l'idée en fait de deux identités qui
sont pas seulement les rares chic mans
positionné mais qu'ils doivent rester
pur dans le suprématisme blanc c'est
très clair et dans supremacy ce moment
c'est la même chose c'est cette idée en
fait le discours la crise de bascule t
basé là dessus c'est l'idée que s'il ya
des éléments qu'on prétend être féminin
qui sont qui entre en contact avec le
masculin on est face à une pathologie
nation une décadence une intoxication
une crise parce qu'on pense en fait
qu'il ya ces deux identités qui sont qui
doivent rester pur qui doivent rester
séparés et donc tout ça puisque excusez
moi je suis un peu trop long mais tout
ça n'est pas trop lourd excuses je
trouve tout ça n'a rien à voir avec le
fait que je considère que les hommes
sont monstrueux concert pas que les
hommes sont monstrueux ne concerne pas
que les femmes sont bonne part par
nature je considère simplement que nous
sommes insérés dans des rapports sociaux
des rapports sociaux c'est-à-dire des
rapports de pouvoir politique des
rapports sociaux de la polio travail au
contrôle des actions contre des
ressources au contrôle de l'espace ou
contrôle du corps des autres dans
lesquels tendanciellement les hommes son
avantage du faso femmes donc c'est une
situation que je considère injustes et
face à cette injustice en tout cas en
principe je me positionne le côté des
féministes contre contre l'esprit
maximale en principe et par ailleurs je
profite je profite de mode mon
positionnement de domme et de mal et
c'est pas c'est pas il ne s'est pas une
haine contre les hommes c'est pas le
fait que les hommes sont obstruées une
dernière question vous dire je connais
pas la question que pense-t-il
d'evergreen
ce qui s'est déjà passé presse a déjà
évolué
c'est quoi une
usine ultra féminine dont evergreen
c'est un film mais j'ai quand ça aurait
servi en compote et la evelyne ça nous
est vaguement quelque chose mais je
pense que l'on sort de mes champs de
compétence là on va arriver à la fin par
contre tu es obligé de revenir parce
qu'il ya eu tellement de questions
il faudra qu'on en fasse une
c'est huit mois quand je serai de retour
en france a évité des femmes avant on a
bien sûr
rapport de forces a expliqué je lui
explique pendant deux heures c'est quoi
la logique de la porte de force
dit oui oui mais voilà et donc je ne
ferme intérêt pour fera notre maximum
pour inviter des femmes d'ailleurs si
vous êtes capable je suis sûr que vous
pouvez nous savoir je passe une annonce
on aimerait avoir
mam michèle alliot marie on aimerait
avoir christine lagarde on est vrai
avoir jodie foster on aimerait avoir
notre astre doute nationale
on débraye avoir tout ça donc n'hésitez
pas à nous filer un coup de main
est-ce que tu as que tu as un conseil
pour les jeunes générations
question vraiment ça veut dire que je ne
suis plus dans la jeune génération c'est
ça
bon
non non je suis un conseil pour les
jeunes générations par la presse qu'on
vient de dire
par rapport à ce que tu
non mais en fait ça tourne en rond un
peu mais je viens de donner plein de
suggestions de livres donc
j'écris des livres on est dans une
émission on part de livres j'aurais
envie de leur dire les lire des livres
si les audi vous avez pas tant c'est
trop embêtant aller chercher des
podcasts en ce moment en plus si on veut
s'informer sur ce qui le féminisme et la
diversité du féminisme et le pluralisme
du féminisme ya tellement plate forme
maintenant on peut faire ce
tranquillement et puis je sais pas je
sais qu'en france vous êtes lake donc
pour le moment vous ne serrez pas noël
mais pour les quelques personnes qui ne
respectent pas la liste xla qui
célèbrent noël bientôt demander des
cadeaux de noël des livres fumer ça y
est les librairies rançon en sont pleins
maintenant on est dans une période où
anf etienne est presque je dirais que je
dis c'est un peu ironiquement mai ou à
la blague mais ya presque une
surproduction de deux lits faits me
laisse en ce moment donc vous avez
l'embarras du choix de femmes d'où je me
rappelais plus le nom c'est claudie
haigneré
on a un hôtel de la dévotion de voile
francis dupuis déri bercy
c'est elle ou mais c'était beau
merci beaucoup de m'avoir reçu en corse
et c'est vraiment très apprécié il vous
fait confiance pour profiter des femmes
la prochaine fois pour la chaîne
française
[Musique]
e